[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
במשך שלושה ימים. חברות הביטוח.
טוב. שלום לכולם.
אז היום אנחנו נמשיך את הדיון שלנו בנושא.
עריכה נתנאל מץ. כן, רשתות נוירונים מרקורי נטיות.
דיברנו על זה ממש על קצה המזלג. בסוף השיעור הקודם אני אחזור על הדברים בקצרה ונמשיך משם קצת יותר.
נצלול לפרטים הטכניים. אני יודע שחלקכם, או אפילו אולי כולכם ראיתם בצורה זו או אחרת את החומר הזה בהאמר, אבל א.
אני חושב ש הפרספקטיבה שם הייתה אולי קצת שונה, וגם שזה לא כלל את כל הדברים כאן, אז שווה להאזין בכל מקרה, כולל לצופים בבית.
אוקיי. אז ככה.
אנחנו בעצם דיברנו. על כן דיברנו די הרבה בקורס הזה עד כה על הנושא בעצם של קונטקסט כן, או קונטקסט links או היסטוריה.
נכון? ובעצם דיברנו על זה שבהרבה מקרים בין ALP אנחנו בעצם עומדים לא מול פרדי פציעות בודדות בלתי תלויות,
אלא מול שורה של פרדי קציצות שאנחנו איכשהו רוצים לבצע אותו באופן אפקטיבי שההפרדה קציצות האלה הן בעצם תלויות אחת בשנייה.
דרך זה שכל אחת צריכה לקחת בחשבון גם את מה שלפעמים קוראים ההקשר שבו היא נאמרה.
כלומר רק כך וכך מילים אחורה או לפעמים גם קדימה, תלוי במודל שנאמרו סביבה.
גם דיברנו על זה שבעצם מצד אחד בעצם לא להניח את התלות הזאת.
מעבד אינפורמציה חשובה, זאת אומרת להתייחס זה כאילו זה פרדי קצוות בלתי תלויות, מעבד אינפורמציה חשובה ומצד שני שלא להניח שום דבר לגבי המבנה.
כן, אלא פשוט ללמוד כל רצף כאיזשהו פתית שלג ייחודי.
גם זה בעייתי, כי זה מוביל אותנו לבעיות דלילות נתונים נוראיות ובגדול.
הכלי שהיה לנו כן, הפטיש שהיה לנו להתמודד עם הקושי הזה או לנסות למצוא איזושהי דרך ביניים בין הגישה שמניחה הנחות,
אי תלות רדיקליות מדי לבין כזאת שלא מניחה שום מבנה.
בגדול נקראה איך נקרא גישה. מרקוב בדיוק הגישה על כן שרשראות מרקוב מודלי מרקוב וראינו אותם בכל מיני מינים וזנים.
כן, הם ימאים ומרכב Language Models ורייצ'ל וכל מיני דברים כאלה, שבכולם בעצם ההנחה הבסיסית שם הייתה שהשרשרת מתפרקת.
בעצם לתת שרשראות קצרות נכון באורך קבוע, שמספיק לנו ללמוד את הסטטיסטיקות שלהם.
נכון והסטטיסטיקות שלהם כבר יתנו לנו משהו רב ערך.
לגבי הסטטיסטיקות של השרשראות כולם בסדר.
זה בגדול הייתה הגישה המקובלת, אבל יש בעיה אם אני אשאר.
מרקוביץ נכון. מה הבעיה היסודית עם הגישה המקובלת כשאנחנו עוסקים בשפה?
של של האורך? כי בעצם השפה היא לא מרקוביץ. השפה היא לא מרקוב.
היא דיברנו על זה נכון לשטויות. גם היום אנחנו נמשיך.
במדרון הזה. יש תלויות רחוקות. אנחנו על ידי זה שפשוט נסתכל על חלון קבוע בגודל, כנראה לא יותר מדי ארוך, כי אחרת לא נצליח להתמודד עם זה.
אנחנו יכולים להגיע עד נקודה מסוימת וזהו.
ובהרבה קשרים נגיד ניתן הדוגמה של סנטימנט analysis למשל.
נכון, כדי להבין את זה שעכשיו הדבר הזה נאמר בהקשר סרקסטי אול כדי להבין שזה כן.
כדי להבין את סך הכל את הסנטימנט של כל הטקסט, הרבה פעמים צריך לקחת בחשבון איזה שהוא חלון יותר גדול.
כן, לא רק, אולי שתיים, שלוש ארבע מילים אחורה, וזה נכון בהרבה הקשרים אחרים.
גם. אז מה בכל זאת עושים? בגדול הכיוון הוא Running.
מה הרעיון של רננים? אז הרעיון הבסיסי הוא כזה?
כן, אם אמרנו ששרשרת מרקוב נגיד אם לדוגמה לציור של שרשרת מרקוב פשוטה כן, במקרה כאן שנותנת הסתברויות סבירות יות לרצפים של Party speech.
אז אם אמרנו השרשרת מעקב הפשוטה הזאת מסדר ראשון?
כן, והיא גם מרקוב צ'יין.
בגדול, מה שהיא עושה זה בעצם היא שומרת על ייצוג של ההיסטוריה של מה שקרה עד עכשיו שמגולם על ידי מה?
מה? מהו ההיסטוריה על פי שיטת מרקוב צ'יין הזה?
אה כן, הפרט ספיץ הקודם שנתקלנו בו נכון באמצעות הפרט הקודם אני מעריך את הסבירות לפרט או ספיץ הבא.
אם זה היה מסדר שני זה היה שתיים, זה היה מסדר שלישי, זה היה 3 וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אבל בוא נגיד שעכשיו, בין כל הקודקודים האלה שפשוט שומרים באופן דטרמיניסטי נוקשה.
תמיד את ההיסטוריה להיות מה שקרה בשלב הקודם או שניים הקודמים או שלוש קודמים.
לא משנה איזשהו מספר קבוע קטן של הקודמים, במקום זה להחזיק פה וקטור.
כן, אז כבר לא יהיה לנו מספר סופי. כן דיסקרטי של מצבים, אלא יהיה לנו וקטור מצבים כאיזשהו וקטור שמייצג את המצב של המערכת באיזשהו מימד קבוע.
אוקיי, וקטור הזה באיזושהי צורה יקודם את מה שחשוב מתוך ההיסטוריה שעד כה ראינו כן הוא איכשהו ייצוג דחוס של הפרטים הרלוונטים של ההיסטוריה הרלוונטיים.
למה? לבית הפרטי, קצה שאותה אנחנו רוצים לפתור. אם זה language מודלינג כדי לחזות את המילים הבאות אם זה סנטימנט.
על CSS כדי לחזות את התוכן, אם זה חיובי או שלילי או ניטרלי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז איך עושים את זה? כן. איך בעצם מחזיקים וקטור שמעדכן את?
כן, את הייצוג של ההיסטוריה בצורה שהיא אדפטיבית.
כלומר. לא פשוט משהו קבוע. מילה אחרונה שתי מילים אחרונות, שלוש מילים אחרונות, אלא משהו שאיכשהו תלוי גם את האינפוט, האינפוט הספציפי.
איך בעצם אנחנו יכולים לייצר כזה דבר? איך אנחנו נשיג את אותה מכונה פלאית ששומרת את מה שחשוב וזורקת את מה שלא חשוב?
אז הרעיון ביניהם הוא בעצם כמו הרבה פעמים ברשתות נוירונים.
שיצא לכם להיתקל בהם כבר לפחות באימייל.
אבל כמו הרבה פעמים ברשתות נוירונים, הרעיון בארנב זה שאנחנו לא ממש מתכננים איך הוא עושה את זה נכון.
אנחנו לא באמת מתכננים איך נראה הווקטור הזה באופן ישיר ואיך מעדכנים אותו על ידי זה שנבין איך משתנה, איך משתנות הקואורדינטות וכן הלאה.
אלא אנחנו מגדירים איזשהו אובייקטים Function נכון או איזשהו loss function ומקווים שהוא
ימצא את הפונקציה הנכונה בתוך מרחב הפרמטרים שעושה את זה באופן אופטימלי ביחס לאותו לא זמן.
נכון, זאת האידיאולוגיה של הגישה הקונבנציונלית.
כן, אפשר להסתכל עדיין על אם תשימו לב עדיין באיזושהי או.
האם אתם יכולים לדעת יותר פרטים על הגוף שלה? נכון נכון, זה עדיין יהיה מדהים מר קובי אבל פשוט ומסוג אחר.
עכשיו המצב אמר קובי הוא א יהיה רציף.
זאת אומרת הוא יהיה וקטור ולא יהיה פשוט סט דיסקרטי של דברים.
וב הפונקציה המעברים היא בעצם תהיה למידה.
כן, זאת אומרת אנחנו. היא הולכת להיות בעצמה איזושהי רשת.
אז איך זה נראה? אז אוקיי, אז איך אפשר לחשוב על זה?
אפשר לחשוב על זה בעצם כשאנחנו רוצים איזשהי רשת נוירונים שמה שהיא לוקחת זה סדרה של וקטור אימפולס.
כן, הווקטור אימפולס האלה הם מקודדים מילים.
אולי נגיד מילה על איך בדיוק וקטורים מקודדים מקודדים מילים תכף, אבל בגדול אנחנו גם נמשיך ונדון בזה בעוד כנראה בשבוע הבא יותר לעומק.
אבל אנחנו חושבים מראש על המילים בתור וקטורים.
אוקיי, ואנחנו רוצים בעצם למפות אותם לסדרה של וקטורים אחרת, שהיא בעצם מייצגת כל פעם את הרישא עד אותה נקודה.
אוקיי, אז S1 יציג את הרכישה של מחרוזת שמתחילה באיקס אחד.
S2 מייצג באיזשהו אופן את הרישא של X של מחרוזת שמתחילה באיקס אחד שתיים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, זה הרעיון, אז אנחנו רוצים לבנות סדרה של איקסים לסדרה של AC.
איך נראה עם האיקסים האלה? אז כאמור, עד אז כל הנושא הזה נקרא נקרא תוכן עם Padding.
זהו void עם Padding. אז כן, איך בדיוק הופכים מילים לווקטור?
ואנחנו נדון בזה יותר לעומק. אבל אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה כדרך אחת פשוטה לעשות את זה.
כן, דרך אחת פשוטה לחשוב על זה זה פשוט כיוון חוט Vector זה כן, כי וקטור היחידה.
אז יש לי כן באוצר המילים שלי לא יודע מאלף מילים, נגיד סתם אני זורק.
אז יש לי ייצוג ממימד 100 אלף וכל מילה היא וקטור יחידה.
בסדר, זה נגיד הצורה הכי פשוטה לייצג את זה. אנחנו נלמד על שיטות יותר מתוחכמות בשבוע הבא.
אוקיי, אז זה מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות. איך אנחנו מוצאים את סדרת הווקטורים הזאת?
אז בעצם מה שאנחנו צריכים זה פונקציה שקוראים לה וכאן function פונקציה רקורסיבית שהיא הפונקציה שבעצם מחליפה את המעברים.
כן, את מטריצת המעברים שהייתה לנו בשרשרת מרקוב היא מקבלת את האיקס, את המילה הנוכחית.
כן, בכל שלב היא מקבלת מילה חדשה ואת הייצוג של הרישא עד אותה נקודה, כמו את כל המילים שקדמו ומייצרת וקטור חדש.
בסדר נושא זה התפקיד שלה. זה איזשהי פונקציה שמקבלת שני וקטורים ממימד קבוע.
אחד מהם מייצג את הרי שעד כה השני מייצג את האיקס ומחשבת וקטור חדש.
עכשיו, ברגע שיש לנו את הפונקציה הזאת, אז בעצם אני יכול לחשב עכשיו כן ברקורסיה את כל העסק גם כן,
בהנחה שזה אותה פונקציה שמופעלת בכל שלב, אז אס ארבע נגיד יהיה פשוט R של אס 3 ו 4.
אבל אס שלוש הוא אר של אס 2 ו x של 3 ו S2 או R של S אחד והסתיים וכן הלאה.
נכון, ואני יכול גם כאן להמשיך ולהפוך את זה ל 0 ואיקס אחד נגיד 10.
הייצוג של של הרישא הריקה. ואני מקבל איזשהו חישוב.
כן, כל מה שאני צריך כדי לחשב את זה זה בעצם לדעת מהר ולדעת שזה בדרך כלל פשוט חלק מהפרמטרים של R.
מה הייצוג שלה, של הרישא הריקה, כן של המחרוזת הריקה, ואז אני יכול לחשב את סדרת הווקטורים הזו.
עכשיו שתי שאלות א. מאיפה מגיעה R הזאת?
כן. וב. איך אני יודע? זאת אומרת איזה וקטורים טובים לי.
למה כן עד פה אמרנו. כל מה שאני צריך זה איזשהו S שייצג את הרישא.
אבל באיזה מובן הוא מייצג את הרישא? כן. מה זה בכלל אומר לייצג את הרי שכן.
מה אני עושה עם האפסים האלה? ומה זה sin טובים?
ומה זה? וכן וקטורי רישא גרועים.
כל הדברים האלה מצלצלים לכם מוכר? או שזה כבר ככה?
קצת ככה עמום בזיכרון?
בין לבין מי כאן יותר נוטה לכיוון המוכר וברור מאליו מי כאן נוטה יותר לכיוון העמום ושווה חזרה?
אוקיי, בסדר, ויש עוד נמנעים, אך אז נעשה את זה לאט לאט.
אז טוב, אז מה אני עושה?
אז בעצם בוא ניקח כן. עכשיו דיברנו ברמה מאוד אבסטרקטית, בוא טיפה יותר, נהיה קונקרטיים.
ונדבר על Instant Scan. על סוג מסוים של פונקציה רקורד.
אז בגדול, פונקציה הרי קוהרנטית הזאת, כפי שאמרתי, היא רשת.
כרשת היא פשוט כן, היא רשת נוירונים כרשת נוירונים.
היא בעצם מורכבת מאיזושהי ארכיטקטורה, נכון ואיזה שהם פרמטרים.
שמגדירים ספציפית במסגרת הארכיטקטורה באיזו רשת אני בוחר נכון?
אגב, אולי אז אתם יודעים מה? אולי נשאל שאלה יותר בסיסית.
אתם כאילו רשתות נוירונים שווה לחזור ממש על זה בקצרה מהתחלה.
לא לא, לא עד כדי כך. אוקיי, בסדר, טוב אחלה.
אז כפי שאתם זוכרים, רשתות נוירונים נכון, יש להם איזושהי ארכיטקטורה ויש להם פרמטרים.
הפרמטרים האלה הם הרבה פעמים נראים כמו מטריצה נכון של פרמטרים שקופל את וקטור שהוא בעצם נכון האינפוט לאותו לפחות לאותו הנוירון או לאותה קבוצת נוירונים,
ובעצם כן איזושהי הזזה בעצם.
במילים אחרות, אלה פשוט הפרמטרים של פונקציה אפינית שעליה פועלת איזשהו נון לינארית היא כמו סיגמא.
היא תנגן, סיפר בולי רדיו וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, עכשיו הנה היא. אז הנה מימוש מסוים לפונקציה הזאת או ארכיטקטורה מסוימת, אם תרצו.
כן, רשת מאוד פשוטה שמורכבת בעצם בשכבה אחת.
כן, זה LMA, כן, על שם כן.
מי שהציע אותה לראשונה בשנות ה 90, פשוט יש לנו כאן פונקציה אפינית שמקבלת את הווקטור איקס כן, את הווקטור של המילה ואת הווקטור של הרישא משרשרת אותם ביחד.
קופל אותם במטריצה DW שזה חלק אחד של הפרמטרים של הפונקציה רקורסיבית ומוסיף לה את הווקטור B.
כן, שהרוח החתיכה השנייה של הפרמטרים, כלומר הפונקציה רקורסיבית כאן הפרמטרים שלהם.
גם הם דאבליו ו B נכון? אז השמות ספציפיות לדבליו ובי קובעים איזה פונקציה רקורסיבית.
מתוך כלל הפונקציות והנטיות שאנחנו שוקלים היא זאת שאנחנו נשתמש בה.
ועכשיו התפקיד שלנו זה לנסות לשערך את דאבליו ו B.
נכון לנסות ללמוד את web מדת. כן, זה בגדול הרעיון.
עכשיו זה אוקיי, אז זה עונה על השאלה הראשונה מה זאת הפונקציה הרפורמית הזאת?
זה מה שלא יהיה שאת תהליך הלמידה יחליט לקבוע את דאבליו ובי מציבים אותם בנוסחה הזאת.
וזאת הפונקציה ביקורתית. השאלה השנייה שהייתה לנו זה מה עושים עם הווקטורים האלה?
כן, למה הם בכלל טובים? למה שנרצה ללמוד אותם? סבבה, יש לנו פונקציה רלוונטית, היא מחזירה לנו וקטורים.
הם מייצגים את הרגישות, אבל למה שבכלל נהיה מעוניינים בכזה דבר?
אז כמובן, התשובה היא כי אנחנו כבר צריכים לעשות איזושהי דיקציה, איזושהי פרי, דיקציה באמצעות הווקטורים האלה.
אז לפי הגישה של אלמן, לפי אותו Instant ספציפי של RNA שהוא הציע, יש לו פונקציה נוספת.
כן, או שהיא פונקצית העודפות? אוקיי, היא מקבלת את הייצוג של המצב של הרשת באיזושהי נקודה, ומחליטה ומחליטה בעצם איזו רדוקציה תצא ספציפית.
הפרדיגמה שכאן היא Soft מקס. כן, זה בעצם התפלגות על פני כן התפלגות על פני על פני לייבלים אפשריים, וגם כאן היא פשוט משהו חד שכבתי, אפילו לינארי.
כן, אפילו בלי נורמלי מיהרתי. כן, פשוט איזשהו פונקציה אפינית שאחרי זה עוברת סוף.
אז כלומר בערך הדבר הכי פשוט שאנחנו הקלאסי פה הרבה ערך פשוט שאנחנו יכולים לחשוב עליו.
כמובן היינו יכולים להחליף את זה בכל רשת אחרת שאנחנו רוצים.
ועכשיו הלמידה כן.
אז השאלה היא אוקיי, אז הגדרנו את הרשת. אנחנו רוצים לעשות פריט דיקציה.
בסדר, אבל כדי שהאפליקציה הזאת תצליח אנחנו צריכים להחליט איך אנחנו מאמנים את הרשת הזאת נכון?
כנגד איזה ג'קטים כן כנגד או כנגד הזה.
לא סממן גשם אם תרצו ובאיזה תהליך ואיזה אלגוריתם כן.
אז אתה יודע מה ההבדל בין פרמטרים על ילדים טרודי דאבליו ובי ודאבל או תג וביט לגבי או אוקיי, אז על ה 19 נקודות אני אעשה 10 15 בסדר?
נכון? אז אולי נציג את זה בדיאגרמה? אולי זה יותר ברור?
שניה אני תכף אני אזכור שהייתה עוד שאלה קצר.
אולי נציג את זה בדיאגרמה זה יהיה יותר ברור.
אז אנחנו חושבים על זה שיש לנו עכשיו סדרה של איקסים בסדר, ובואו נגיד שלכל אחד מהם אנחנו רוצים לבצע ספרי דיקציה.
בסדר, אולי חלק מהם לא מעניינים אותך, אולי רק האחרונה מעניינת אותך ולא משנה כרגע.
בוא נגיד שכולם אתה רוצה לבצע לכל אחד פדי קצר.
אז אתה מכניס את איקס אחד. כן, יש איזשהו אפס אפס שגם זה אפשר לחשוב עליו גם כפרמטר של הרשת.
כן כאיזשהו. כן או או לא משנה או או שזה מה שאר מחזירה כשאתה מאזין כשאתה מאזין לאיזשהו default value שמייצג את הרשת ריקה.
לא קריטי פה. נחשוב על זה כחלק מהפרמטרים של הרשת. איזשהו בתור ראשוני הדבר הזה נכנס בעצם לתוך הקופסה הזאת יחד עם הייצוג של איקס אחד.
אוקיי, עכשיו הקופסה הזאת יודעת לעשות שני דברים יודעת להפעיל את הפונקציה ביקורתית.
אוקיי, הפונקציה ביקורתית הזאת לוקחת את S אפס ואת איקס אחד ופולטת וקטור באותו מימד כמו כמו אס אפס.
אוקיי, פונקציה או לוקחת את אס אפס ופולטת באמצעותו ואולי את איקס אחד גם ופולטת באמצעותו את וואי אחד.
אוקיי, את הפרדוקס של שהנגיד את הסוף, את Output של הסוף, זאת שהיא התפלגות על פני ערכים.
עכשיו מה ששונה מן הפונקציה הזאת בדיאגרמה הזאת לעומת פשוט נגיד fed forward נט שאנחנו מכירים ואוהבים, זה שאם תשים לב יש לנו כאן ט זה הפרמטרים של המודל.
במקרה של הדוגמה הקודמת זה בעצם דאבליו בי ודאבל תג בתג נכון, אלה בעצם ואס אפס.
בעצם כן. אז בעצם הפרמטרים האלה הם משותפים.
אתה רואה, הקווים האפורים האלה בעצם מצביעים לכל הקופסאות, כי בעצם זה אותה פונקציה, אותה זוג פונקציות שפועלות בכל אחד מהם.
בעצם יש לנו כאן. כן, לפעמים קוראים לזה וויט שרינג.
כן, בעצם אתה חוזר, אתה מפעיל את אותם Watch בעצם, או במילים אחרות אתה מפעיל את אותם הפונקציות הרבה Or בכל שלב.
כשמה שמשתנה זה פשוט הערכים של איקס ואס שנכנסים לתוך הקופסה.
אוקיי, זה הבנים של פול. וואי וואי זה פשוט ה output!
אז נגיד output אם הוא soft מקס אז כן זה אתה רוצה לעשות קלאסי?
פיקציה על עשרה ערכים אז זה פשוט יהיה ווקטור של הסתברויות באורך עשר.
מה שאנחנו רוצים לשפר תכף נראה ספציפית איך אנחנו משתמשים בזה בשפה.
כרגע אני עוד מציג את זה בצורה אבסטרקטית. כן. סיקרט.
הוא מאורס לאורך המשפט. לא, לא אמרתי קבוע הוא אורח קבוע.
או למעשה לא יכול להיות תלוי באורך המשפט. יש לו מימד קבוע בתוך הפונקציה של התא.
אה? הסכמים קודמים. אוקיי. יכול להיות ש.
אז בעצם מה? לא, אין זה לא המימד פה.
אין זה האינדקס. כלומר זה הייצוג של הרי איקס אחד עד X אצל מינוס אחד או הייצוג של הרי שהיא צריכה השכבה שלו.
אז בכל שכבה של בינארי.
אנחנו משתפים אפליקציה. נכון, אותה פונקציה פועלת בדיוק מה שמשתנה זה הקיבוץ של הזיכרון.
עכשיו ביחידות האלה אתה יכול לחזור. רגע, כן.
ביחידות האלה אנחנו מזכירים את המילה הראשונה ואז את המילה הראשונה והשנייה, ואז את המילה הראשונה.
לא לא, הנה תשים לב, תשימו לב איך זה פועל.
האב תמיד מקבל בדיוק שני הארגומנט עם אותם הארגומנט.
אם זה ייצוג של רישא וייצוג של התוכן.
המילה הנוכחית כן, פעם אחת זה יהיה הייצוג של הראשה ריקה והמילה הנוכחית בפעם הבאה זה ייצוג של הרישא באורך אחד וכן הלאה.
אבל אבל אבל מבחינת הרשת זה פשוט וקטור. היא לא יודעת שזה מבוסס על אחד או אפס או שמונת אלפים.
כן, אנחנו רואים את הראשון. יש איזה זיכרון, איזה אפס, אחד משתיים שלוש זה לא מספיק?
איפה כן? אז זה הראשון, נגיד בראש הזה איקס אחד.
הטקסט 5 נגיד, אבל רק. לא, אבל S5 היא פונקציה גם של X4 וגם שX לא רק תיאורטית.
קידוד כלשהו היא קידוד כלשהו בדיוק כן, כפי שאתם רואים.
S4 הוא פונקציה של איקס אחד איקס שתיים, שלוש, ארבע.
אקס חמש הוא פונקציה של אקס 5, יצר את שלה שכשלה עם אפס אחד וכן הלאה.
כן, יש עוד דיאגרמה. אולי לפעמים יותר נוח לראות את זה ככה.
זה בדיוק אותו דבר כמו הדיאגרמה הקודמת. זה פשוט שקול. אז שוב תיזכרו באלמנט.
נכון, מה שיש לנו זה בעצם מטריצות מסדר גם באינסטגרם, אבל בוא נגיד שהן נבלעו גם בתוך המוטציה הזאת.
כן, אז מה שיש לנו זה איזה שהן מטריצות או איזשהם פונקציות אפיניות.
כן. כאן, אם מסומן כאן המסומנים בתור חיובי, כן, זה R והר ו או בעצם או הפרמטרים של r ואור.
ומה שיש לי זה איזה שהוא ייצוג אפס.
כן ייצוג של הרי שהרקע הוא קופל את יו.
כן את הפרמטרים של הפונקציה. הרי קורנט כן עובר.
תארגן היפרבולי. הגענו ל.
כן, הגענו ל. אין פה את אחד לעץ אחד.
לא סליחה מה שהוא עושה באלמנט, סליחה, תיקון טעות באלמנט.
מה שעושה את זה אפס. קופא לתיאור משורשיו.
אם האיקס אחד או במקרה כאן יש כאן עוד מטריצה שמתווך את בין זה לבין איקס אחד, למשל, זה כבר עניין של מימוש.
זה טיפונת שונה אז מהאל מן, אבל מאוד דומה. כן, זה פשוט דאבליו אקס אחד נכנס פה במקום אקס אחד ישירות.
אז דאבליו איקס אחד עובר שרשור עם יו אס אפס.
נכון, זה יוצר את מה שקראנו לו עץ אחד ועכשיו העץ אחד הזה מזין שני חישובים.
חישוב אחד זה כדי לפלוט את וואי אחד, נכון?
אז הוא קופל בפונקציה אפינית של אור ובסוף מקס נגיד או מה שלא יהיה שנוי האור ועוד פעם ביום כדי
לקבל חצי ראשון של האינפוט שהפונקציה וקוהרנטית של ההפעלה הבאה של החצי השני מגיע מ דאבליו H2.
שוב זה H2 מזין את פונקציית output שפולטת את y שתיים ואת החישוב של אס 3 וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
בסדר. כך שכפי שאתם רואים הדיאגרמה הזאת בצורה פשוטה כל וואי איי בעצם הוא פונקציה של מה של איזה אם פותחים.
והעסק הזה של העסקים, שהם בתורם כפונקציה של פונקציה של האיקסים, נכון?
כלומר אז איזה איקס?
וואי שלוש הוא פונקציה של אחת הוא וואי שלוש שהוא פונקציה של איזה איקסים אחד אחד שלו בדיוק אחד עד 3 נכון וכנל לגבי כל כולה בסדר אז זה חשוב.
כן זה חשוב בגלל שבעצם הרעיון כאן הוא שאנחנו רוצים שתאורטית כמובן תלוי באם הפונקציות כן שמסומנת פה ביו דאבליו ביו ודבילי עובדות כמו שצריך.
כן, אבל תיאורטית הוא יכול לזכור מה שקרה.
גם מיליון צעדים אחורה. נכון, אנחנו תכף נראה שהמצב קצת יותר מסובך מזה, אבל תיאורטית לפחות הוא פונקציה של כל מה שקדם ממה שקדם הוא באורך מיליון.
אז הוא גם פונקציה שלו. כן יכול לזכור בסדר.
שאלות עד כאן. אוקיי.
כן, וזה לפעמים קוראים לזה Android View של Arena.
כן, אז לפעמים כן. Unreal. כאילו כן, במקום לעשות את זה, מין קופסה נחמדה כזאת אחת בעצם רואים כאן את המבנה באמת של גרף החישוב.
נכון באמת המבנה של גרף החישוב או משהו כזה כל פעם הפעלה אינטראקטיבית של של אותם קבוצות.
טוב, אז עכשיו אנחנו.
אז זה הצורה של הרשת ועכשיו אנחנו צריכים ממש לקוות שבאמת ערוץ One ילמדו כמו שצריך.
נכון? ובאמת ארסנל מידע ככה איי יחזיק בתוכו אינפורמציה.
הוא יחזיק בתוכו פיצ'רים שאחרי זה יאפשרו לאור לפלוט את הפרי דיקציה הנכונה.
נכון, והוא לא שכח כל מיני פרטים חשובים מהעבר שהם בעצם קריטיים כדי לחזות את הלייבל הנוכחי.
אז איך אנחנו עושים את זה? איך אנחנו מכילים?
כן. איך אנחנו מאמנים את הפרמטרים של הרשת שפשוט נקרא להם טאטע קט הזה מכיל.
מכניס כן, כרגיל, מכניס את כל הפרמטרים גם של פונקציה ביקורתית, גם של output function.
כל הפרמטרים ביחד נקרא להם תטא. אז איך אנחנו מאמנים את הדבר הזה כך שיתפקד כמו שצריך בשאיפה?
אז אוקיי, אז אני מזכיר מה שצריך להגדיר. זה לא שפה חדשה, נכון?
ככה זה תמיד צורת האימון ברשתות.
אנחנו צריכים להגדיר איזשהו lose function הלא function הזה.
בעצם מה שהוא מקבל זה את הכניסה שהוא input עם התשובה הנכונה שלו והוא מקבל את הפרס דיסקציה של הרשת או באופן שקול את הפרמטרים של הרשת.
למה אני אומר באופן שקול? כן, בדיוק.
זה הדבר היחידי שאני מזיז. אז כאילו טאטע בעצם אני יכול לחשב אם יש לי את איקס איי ואת טאטע.
אני יכול לחשב את הפונקציה של הרשת. נכון שעושה פה ספרות אז?
אז אז בעצם יש לי פלוס הוא פונקציה של תטא ושל.
של איזשהי דוגמה עם ה school solution שלה wifi.
ועכשיו אני לוקח את הממוצע האמפירי על פני כל דוגמאות האימון ואני רוצה למסור אותו בסדר.
אני רוצה למזער אותו אולי עם רגולרי הזיה.
כל הדברים שלמדתם בעמל בסדר עדיין תקפים גם כאן, אבל slow function אני לוקח אז כמובן תלוי בios case, אבל אז בוא ניקח ייעוץ קייסים יקרים וחשובים.
אז למשל, בואו ניקח את הבעיה של סנטוריני טרנר שדיברנו עליה.
כן, מישהו מישהי רוצים להזכיר מה שמתי מתנוסס?
לראות אם משפט? כן בגדול.
מה הבעיה? תפריט דיקציה מה input output? נגיד אם זה פוליטי פשוט ברדק פוליטי זה משפט.
זה גבוה? כן, בדיוק.
כלומר, אם הוא מכבד עמדה חיובית. נגיד מכניסים איזשהו טקסט, ביקורת על מדפסת, סרט, טוויט פוליטי, וואטאבר.
מכניסים איזשהו טקסט וצריך לחזות במקרה הכי פשוט פלוס או מינוס חיובי או שלילי,
ואמרנו שאנחנו קצת נתקענו שם עם זה שתכלס כנראה צריך לקחת בחשבון את כל המילים.
אבל בגבוה ארץ לא מספיק נכון. דיברנו על זה.
אנחנו אפילו לא יודעים עם שלילה מה לעשות בביג וולץ, כי פשוט מופיע שם איפשהו, ואפשר לעשות כל מיני היקים, אבל גם הם בעייתיים.
מי שלא זוכרים את זה מוזמנים לחזור לפרק על סנטימנט analysis, אבל בגדול קצת נתקענו בקיר שם כי אמרנו אנחנו לא יכולים לעשות באג וורד.
אפשר לעשות כל מהקיים כדי לתקן בפועל את זה, אבל הם לא לגמרי משכנעים.
אנחנו עכשיו צריכים לקחת בחשבון את כל המשפט כן או את כל הטקסט.
אז איך עושים את זה? אז הנה רעיון אחד לאיך לעשות את זה עם Running זה לקוח ממאמר.
מי שמתעניין ככה בהצגה המלאה שלו יש פה את השם מ 2017 והרעיון הוא בעצם כזה.
אז יש לנו את הטקסט. כן, את ה input נגיד המילים אוקיי, מסומנים כ איקסים כרגיל.
אוקיי, עכשיו מה שהם עשו זה בעצם הם בנו שתי רשתות רקורד הטיות שמקבלות את אותו רצף איקסים.
בסדר. לאחד הם קראו forward ולשני הם קראו הביקורת, אבל בגדול כל אחת מהם היא פשוט רשת רקורד פשוטה.
תכף תראו את הנוסחאות רשת רקורד פשוטה. ההבדל היחידי ביניהם זה שהאחת מהם בעצם מקבלת את האיקסים לפי הסדר, והשנייה מקבלת אותם מהסוף להתחלה.
אוקיי, אז בעצם האחת היא ה HOT חץ קדימה.
אני לא יודע אם אתם רואים מספיק טוב. כן יש באחד חץ קדימה ופה יש חץ אחורה.
כן? אז מה ההבדל בין HD חץ קדימה והשני חץ אחוריים?
שניהם מקבלים את סדרת האיקסים 49 זה בדיוק 1.
זה כל המילים עד בעצם קיבל באופן רקורסיבי כן את כל המילים עד תא והשני כל המילים.
מתי והלאה אחלה. ושני הדברים האלה כן יש שם עכשיו.
Output function טיפונת יותר מורכב מ שראינו קודם, אבל לא דרמטית.
הוא פשוט מקבל גם את HD קדימה וגם את HD אחורה.
בסדר, גם את הייצוג של החישה וגם את של הסי פה ועושה איתם משהו.
כן מבצע איזושהי פרוטקציה עכשיו, למה שירצו לעשות את זה בעצם?
מה היה להם רע עם גודארד? Fashion forward ארנה כן, שמה רגע, אתה מקבל רק את כל הטקסט ממה שהיה לפני במשפט.
זה מאוד יפה. אתה צריך לשים פה מבחינת צבעים. כן, בדיוק.
זאת אומרת, הם אמרו אנחנו מנסים לעשות איזושהי פרידה. פציעת הדיקציה הזאת אפנדיציט שלוקח בחשבון את כל הטקסט.
אנחנו רוצים לקחת בחשבון גם קדימה, גם אחורה היה ניתן לשאול.
ובאמת אנשים גם עשו לי פעם עבודות כאלה. אני אגיד במאמר מוסגר אז אפשר היה להגיד בסדר, אבל ממילא אנחנו צריכים רק לייבל אחד לכל הסדרה.
למה שלא נסתכל פשוט על Y? אין כאילו על הY האחרון.
אוקיי, אז תזכרו את השאלה הזאת. אנחנו נגיע אליה טיפה טיפה בהמשך.
נכון, גם היה אפשר לעשות את זה ובאמת יש אנשים שעושים את זה, אבל יש סיבה שהם עבדו ככה.
על כל פנים, זאת צורה מאוד פופולארית. זה נקרא לפעמים by arena.
כן, כי כאילו זה בידיים שלנו במקום הכיוון. אחלה.
ואיך נראה? איך נראים? איך נראות הנוסחאות?
אז בגדול מה שיש לנו זה שאת כאילו הפונקציה רקורד זה שם איזושהי פונקציה רקורסיבית שאנחנו לומדים שלוקחת את.
כן, שבעצם לוקחת את XT ואת הייצוג של הרשע.
אחד עד טים מינוס אחד פלוס. מה היא עשתה ומחשבת את HD קדימה?
יש לנו בעצם נוסחה אנלוגית לחלוטין לHTC אחורה.
כן שלוקחת את הייצוג של XT ואת הייצוג של הסעיף ה HD ועוד אחד ואת הבא ישר של H אחורה.
כן ומחשבת את HTC אחורה ואת wait שהיא בעצם מה שכתוב כאן זה output function שהוא
במקרה הזה פשוט לינארי ויש לו מטריצה שמכפיל לה את חלק מהפרמטרים של המודל.
את HD קדימה, עוד מטריצה שמחזירה את HOT אחורה ועוד BIOS וקטור שלה.
בסדר, מה זה הוא איטי? אגב, מה הוא יוצר בסוף?
באיזה אופן כן? אז מה שחשוב מה שכתוב כאן זה באמת החישוב של האור.
אך מה הפרמטרים של המודל הזה שקצת? עד כאן לא מצאתי את כל המטריצה.
נכון דאבליו. של השורה העליונה בשורה העליונה יש שתי מטריצות בשורה האמצעית יש עוד שתי מטריצות.
בשורה השלישית יש עוד שתי מטריצות ויש לנו כל שורה בעשר, נכון?
אז גם כל הדברים האלה ביחד זה התא, זה הפרמטרים של המותג?
כן. מה ההבדל בין הדברים? שני.
הצדדים על הדגלים פעמיים בעצם בצדדים.
לא הבנתי. אה? פשוט רציתי לסמן שזה לא אותה מטריצה.
אז אחת מהם זה בעצם דאבליו של הפונקציה הביקורתית כאילו של שמה, שמקבל את החלופה יותר קוהרנטית של מה שמקבל את ה state הקודם.
כן החץ. כן, פתח.
אז ככה. אז כדי לחשב את HTC חץ קדימה צריך לקחת את HTC מינוס אחד חץ קדימה ואת XP שלו עם החצים.
עכשיו IPC מכפל מאיזושהי מטריצה. כן.
HD מינוס אחד מוכפל באיזושהי מטריצה. זה לא אותה מטריצה.
הם לא בהכרח חייבים להיות אפילו מאותו מימד. נכון? אחרי שלפי הנוסחה הזאת, אחרי תלת מימד, הפלט של המטריצות האלה הוא כן מאותו מימד,
כלומר מספר מימד השורות שלהם הוא כן אותו מימד, אבל המימד העמודות לאו דווקא אותו מימד.
זה לשתי מטריצות שונות פלוס יש לך עוד שתי מטריצות שעושות את הכיוון ההפוך.
את יכולה לעשות העניין בצד השני, אבל. כן, לפעמים עושים סטיילינג.
נכון, היה אפשר לשנות את המוטציה, לפעמים גם כן, לפעמים גם עושים את הדבר הזה כמה פעמים.
כן, ומזינים את זה לעוד פונקציה רקורסיבית שמקבלת את הייצוגים של הפונקציה.
יש כל מיני. כן, אפשר את הדבר הזה מאוד מסובך, אבל בחרתי את המאמר הזה כי הוא סך הכל עושה משהו מאוד פשוט.
אז יש לנו עכשיו wait בסדר. Wait הזה הוא פשוט וקטור.
כן, הוא וקטור ממשי באיזשהו מימד שקבענו נכון לפי הפרמטרים של המודל.
אז הוא איזשהו וקטור ממשי. אז מה קיבלנו?
קיבלנו אאוטפיטים שהם לכל מילה.
איזשהו וקטור ממשי במימד קבוע זה לא מה שרצינו, נכון?
מה רצינו בדיוק? אחד או אפס או פלוס אחד מינוס אחד?
אז יפה. אז מה הם עשו בעצם עם אותם הY?
מה שהם עשו זה הם מצאו אותם. כן, את כל הווים הם ביצעו עלינו,
קראו לזה Y ואז הכניסו סיגמא יד שפשוט הופך את הY עם האלה כן סיגמא יד או סופט מקס בגודל שתיים זה בעצם אותו דבר שהופך את זה.
הסתברויות כן להסתברות לפלוס והסתברות למינוס. עכשיו בגדול האינטואיציה.
אוקיי, ואני אגיד משהו לפני אינטואיציה מהשלב שאנחנו מתחילים לדבר על רשתות, כפי שאתם בוודאי זוכרים, מאיימים כבר אין הוכחות.
אז אתם לא תראו. כן, זה נפנופי ידיים בגדול.
למה הם בחרו דווקא את הארכיטקטורה הזאת ולא אחרת?
למה הם חיברו אותם ולא עשו חיבור מושכל?
למה הם עשו את הפרי? דיקציה באמצע ולא רק בסוף כל הדברים האלה.
אין אין אין הוכחה. אבל אני יכול להסביר שנייה מה האינטואיציה שלהם הייתה.
כן, האינטואיציה בעצם אומרת ככה הם אומרים.
תראו, אם אנחנו כשאנחנו רוצים לתת, כשאנחנו רוצים לתת ערך סנטימנט כן, פלוס מינוס לטקסט מסוים, אנחנו בעצם עושים את זה באיזושהי צורה שהיא אינפורמציה.
כן, שהיא מיודעת על ידי ערך הסנטימנט של המילים שמרכיבות את זה עכשיו.
איך הסנטימנט של המילים שמרכיבות זה לא משהו שתלוי רק במילה?
גם זה תלוי בהקשר נכון, כי אולי כתוב שם גוד, אבל אנחנו כמה מילים לפני כן כתוב Not ולענות על זה.
אולי מתייחס לקוד, אולי לא מתייחס. צריך להבין. צריך להבין בדיוק מה אומר שמה גוד.
אם זה חיובי שלילי זה לא זה ולא זה אז אז גם זאת באת פרי.
דיקציה? כן, זה מורכבת. כן, זה לא פשוט שנלמד את זה בגופו.
את זה פשוט כזה. ולא בלי נייר מודל. אז אנחנו בעצם להפריד את זה לשני שלבים כדי לתת איזשהו סוג של אינדקס בייס לרשת.
מה הם שני השלבים? השלב ראשון זה שלב שבו אני זה שלב שבו אני חוזה לכל מילה את הלייבל שלה.
כן, עכשיו זה לא בדיוק את הלייבל שלה, כי אנחנו חושבים אולי זה משהו קצת יותר מורכב מפשוט לייבל, אז אני לא אלך זה לשכלל.
אולי אני אחזיר הווקטור כן, כדי שיהיה לו קצת יותר אקספרסיביות.
זה כבר איזשהו היפר פרמטר של המודל. כן. מה המימד של הוואי?
אולי הוא סקלר? כן, ואז אני פשוט חושב עליו. אולי כי כמה זה חיובי או שלילי?
כן, אולי זה וקטור אז הוא יכול לייצג אולי כמה מימדים.
אולי זה אפשר לעשות פרי דיקציה יותר טובה ואז אני עושה איזושהי אגרגציה עם כולם.
אגרגציה הזאת היא כן בגב Words סוג של או בגבוה את זי במובן הזה שאני פשוט ממצה את כולם בלי חשיבות לסדר,
בלי הזה הרננדז פשוט לוקח את כולם ומחבר אותם ביחד, ועל זה אני עושה ועל זה אני לומד.
משקולות זה בעצם הפיצ'רים שלי. כן, עליהם אני לומד משקולות ולא גלילי המודל וככה אני מבצע את הפריטים.
אז כאילו באיזשהו מובן זה מקודדת. האינטואיציה שאומרת כדאי.
הצורה שבה חוזים סנטימנט היא צריכה לפעול בצורה שקודם אנחנו מבינים את המילים בתוך הקונטקסט ועד כמה המילים האלה חיוביות או שליליות בקונטקסט שהן נמצאות,
או אולי עוד כמה מימדים.
אבל אנחנו מנסים להבין מה המילים האלה אומרות בקונטקסט שלהם מבחינת סנטימנט, ואז פשוט דוחפים את הכל לשק ומשם מריצים פרויקט זה כן יכול.
הוא בעצם לייבל למילה שגם עכשיו אנחנו תכף נגיע לאימון.
לגבי השאלה כי עקרונית אין לך לייבל למילים, נכון, יש לך רק לייבלים למשפטים, אבל תשים לב שכרגע כל מה שאתה צריך זה לייבלים למשפטים.
כל מה שאתה צריך זה להגדיר לוס. כן, על הסגמנט הזה כן צריך להגדיר לא עושה לעסק מוריד הזבל.
אתה יכול להשתמש רק בלייבל של משפטים. יכול להיות שזה לא יהיה סיגנל מספיק חזק?
כן. אז אנחנו אולי תכף נדבר על זה, אבל עקרונית לא חייבת.
כן לא לא, לא חייבת את המודל להתאמן ברמת מילה.
אוקיי. בסדר. אז אם לסכם את הכן את הדיון עד כאן.
אז אה. רננים יכולים, לפחות באופן עקרוני, כן, אנחנו אולי לא בדיוק מבינים איך כן, כי זה תלוי בכמה טוב תהליך האימון,
ואם הצלחנו באמת למצוא פערים טובים כן, פונקציה קוראת יותר טובות, אבל לפחות באופן עקרוני הם יכולים לקחת בחשבון את כל הקונטקסט.
כן את כל הריגשי. אם חשוב לנו גם הסיפא כן, אז אנחנו יכולים לקחת אחד שרץ מקדימה.
כן מהתחלה לסוף אחד שרץ מסוף להתחלה ו לשרשר אותם ביחד או לקחת את שניהם איכשהו בחשבון.
עקרונית זה גם יכול לקודד את הסדר הלינארי באיזושהי צורה בין המילים.
שוב תלוי בפונקציה הרלוונטית. אבל המידע הזה נמצא שם.
כי כן, כי זה לא סימטרי. נכון, זה לא אותו דבר.
להזין לרשת את X 3 ואז בתור הבית X 4 כמו להאזין לו אחד את X 4 ואחריו את איקס 3 אתם תקבלו תוצאה אחרת.
האם היא תהיה מה שאתם רוצים שהיא תהיה? זאת כבר שאלה.
כן, אבל לפחות באופן עקרוני המידע הזה איכשהו קיים.
כן, הסימטריה הזאת של בגבול בין המילים בפוזיציות שונות נשברת.
ובאמת המודלים מהסוג הזה מראים שיפור משמעותי בביצועים, בייחוד בכל מיני משימות, כולל סנטימנטלי, בסיס ובאופן כללי במשימות שצריכות מצד אחד מבנה של המשפט.
זה באמת לא מספיק להם באגו פוינטס, אבל מצד שני הם צריכות מבנה שהוא מעבר למבנה לוקאלי המיידי של שם מעקב Models מצטיינות.
החיסרון הברור כבר עוד לפני שדיברנו אפילו על אימון, והאם נצליח למצוא את פונקציית רקורד הנטיות טובות?
זה שעכשיו הסטייט Seconds אנחנו לא יודעים לפרש אותו ממש נכון.
זה פשוט איזשהו וקטור מה? כמה טוב וקטור נתון פשוט הוא טוב לפי האיכות.
כאילו שבעזרתו אני מסוגל לבצע הדיקציה אחרי זה עם האו כן או או טוב כמה הוא טוב כפיטר לרשת אחרת שאולי משתמשת בזה,
אבל אין איזושהי אינטרפרטציה אם טרנזיט כן לווקטור שמייצגים את כן את הרשת ואת השאיפות.
וכמובן מה שזה אומר זה שאנחנו לא לגמרי בטוחים מה הרשת הזאת לוקחת או לא לוקחת בחשבון מההקשר, וזה דורש חקירה נוספת שאנחנו נדון בזה אחרי ההפסקה.
הזמן לשאלות קצרות? כן, אז כאילו בעצם אין משמעות.
זה בגלל הסויה. הטקסט.
אין להם קונטקסט. כן, בהחלט. זאת אומרת, באופן עקרוני המודל הזה הוא מודל שהייצוג שלו, של המילים.
הוא בעצם הצורה שבה הוא מתאמן. תיזכרו איך אנחנו מגדירים לא ספק שהוא בסוף לא.
לא ספאם כשהם פשוט על ה output של הרשת.
כלומר, כמה הוא מנסה בעצם לשנות את הפרמטרים של הרשת, כך שהטקסטים חיוביים יקבלו הסתברות כמה שיותר גבוהה וטקסטים שליליים יקבלו הסתברות כמה שיותר נמוכה.
אין שום ערובה לכך שההומואים שהוא מוציא.
אפילו אם הם היו סקלר. כן, אפילו אם הם היו חד מימדיים היו משהו סביר שאנחנו יודעים להבין אותו, ולמעשה יכול להיות שזה משהו שאנחנו בכלל לא יודעים להבין.
הוא לא מקודד שום דבר שדומה האינטואיציות שלנו לגבי האם מילים של להיות או חיוביות,
כל עוד הוא ממלא את תפקידו ומאפשר לה, או כן או למה שהוא מזין אותו לבצע.
הדיקציה איכותית. אני לא ספק שניתן לא נמוך.
הפרמטר הזה התקדם במעלה האופטימיזציה.
כן? בסופו של דבר מה היה הבעיה?
כשאנחנו צריכים לקבוע את הפרס. גדול מדי.
מידי פעם אני שוכח גם שאנחנו צריכים לקבוע וגם שאנחנו מאוד מוגבלים בגלל שאנחנו צריכים לשמור פרמטרים לכולם.
גם אנחנו. כאילו שאם לא, לא רק זה עם הפיצ'רים איכשהו התגברנו עם מימי.
ואני מתכוון שאם אתה בחרת שרשרת מערכות מסדר חמש, אז עכשיו אתה צריך לזכור את כל החמישיות או את כל ה שישיות.
כן, לא רק חלק ראשון. לפעמים זה בדיוק לפעמים זה לא נדרש עשרה ואז למלא טופס ואז אנחנו רוצים דרך.
הכוונה לקבל זיכרון של.
אנו רואים אדפטיבי אקטיבי כן? האם זה לא מוגזם הרבה יותר מדי?
הסינים היו יכולים להכיל יותר ולקבל יותר טובה זהות.
פשוט להגדיר. הנה אפשרויות לשכוח.
הנה אפשרות לזכור דברים, אולי לשכוח.
אל תדאג, אתה קצת דחפנו פה את כל הקונטקסט.
אנחנו אומרים את זה, כולל את זה קדימה. כן או לא?
א. אולי, אבל בעצם כל הרעיון.
אני לא יודע כמה דיברו איתכם באי מייל, כאילו על האידאולוגיה של רשתות נוירונים,
אבל האידיאולוגיה שם בעצם אומרת את הדבר הבא, היא אומרת אל תלך ותנסה להנדס את המערכת יותר מדי.
תהיה מינימלית מן Intervention. כן, תגדיר את הארכיטקטורה בסדר שם.
כן, צריך כנראה, לפחות ברמה הבסיסית, בן אדם שיחליט איך נראה,
איך נראית משפחת הפונקציות שאתה רוצה לחדד, איך נראית הרשת, אבל משם אל תנסה להנדס את זה יותר מדי.
הרשת הרבה יותר טובה ממך בלמצוא את התבניות הסטטיסטיות שהכי טובות כדי למזער את הלוז.
אז תן לה לעשות את העבודה הזאת ותישאר אתה בדברים שאתה טוב.
בלעשות אותם זה פחות או יותר אוקיי, אז נמשיך אחרי ההפסקה.
כן, נחזור באחת משתי דקות. הבאתי גם הרבה דברים שאתה.
עושה. אהלן. מה הוא רע?
שאלה גדולה. התשובה בטוח.
תראה, התחום עובר שינויים די רציניים.
אז במובן הזה גם אני לא לגמרי בטוח, אבל בגדול מה שמעניין אותי זה דברים שנמצאים על התפר בין NLP לבין קוגניציה בלשנות.
זאת אומרת, איך אני יכול להשתמש ביכולת לחזור NLP כדי ללמוד משהו על שפה או על שפות, או ללמוד משהו על תפיסת השפה או למידת השפה או או מבנה של סיפורים.
כן, כל מיני מבנים שונים של טקסטים, של משפטים או אתה יודע, תלוי בהקשר.
לדוגמה, איך שפות נבדלות זו מזו. זה נגיד היא דוקטורנטית שעשתה אז.
המטרה הייתה לא לפתח טכנולוגיה חדשה, אלא המטרה הייתה ללמוד באמצעות כלים חישוביים וקורסים.
ואתה יודע, בשיטות המתקדמות של ענפי בעצם לימוד על כל מיני תבניות שבהם שפות דומות אחת לשנייה שונות אחת מהשנייה, או דוקטורנט אחר שעומד לסיים.
עכשיו הוא התעסק במבנה של סיפורים. כן, ושוב ניסה להבין דברים האלה, אך המבנה ידוע שיש לסיפורים איזשהו מבנה.
מצד שני, המבנה הזה זה לא כמו מבנה דקדוקי. זה לא שכל סיפור אתה יודע, בדרך כלל סיפורים שהם יותר מדי Template, הם יותר מדי הולכים לפי איזשהו מבנה.
קונבנציה עם data די משעממים. אז הסיפורים דווקא יש איזה שהם יחסים דיאלקטי עם המבנה, אבל זה עדיין שאלה מעניינת.
איך בדיוק מבטאים את זה, נגיד? דוגמה אחרת.
בקיצור כל מיני דברים שאני חושב יותר קשורים לאיך אני יכול ללמוד משהו באמצעות ולא לפתח.
שזה משהו שאני עושה חשבון לתעשייה, אבל זה לא משהו שבאמת צריך.
מכיר אותה. זה לא היה משהו, אבל אתה חושב.
כל הזמן, אתה יודע, זה משתנה. אני כבר שם לא מעט שנים. לא, זה ממש משתנה, אבל זה לא אותו הדבר.
היום. המערכות נגד Against הם הרבה יותר מודלי שפה.
הם בעצם מודלי שפה לא נכון.
בדיות של ההיסטוריה. זה כפי שאתה יודע. זה לא הבדלי שפה.
זה בעצם משהו שקיים מערכת הפעלה כזאת שוטפת של שפה.
אבל ככה זה קורס מקדים. מנהלת משאבים שעושה שימוש למקצועיות, מקבלת החלטות, משנה קשר, להתעסק בטיסה.
מעבר לזה אתה יודע לדבר עליו ממש כאילו, כאילו גם כל דבר.
אז נספח תובנות חדשות באקדמיה זה הספר.
מבחינת משאבים לבדוק עם החברות הגדולות.
יש להם שלושה צוותי מהנדסים. שנים אני משקיע בזה כסף, לא רואה פה שום.
אלא אם מישהו בא עם איזה משהו לבצע בדיקה כזאת.
מכיוון שאף אחד לא חשב על שבת זה נהדר. עכשיו אתה מבינה שיש הרבה פחות כי אתה כל שנה פותח את הפה לספורטאים ולמשפחות המון.
ואתה יודע, אפילו אם היה לך מישהו בבית שהוא עובד אז הכסף עדיין אני.
אם אתה בטוח שהוא עובד אתה יודע. כנראה תצטרך הרבה לספוג את הרושם שאתה צריך.
אז. כל השאר מפסידים.
לזכות בכרטיסים. מה זה הבדלים בין שפות?
נגיד למשל? במשפחה?
אז יש שאלה נגיד איזה ספר? איזה קונספטים עוברים לפיסיקה, לאיזה עצים, כלומר מקבלים מידע ואיזה לא שמשבש השפות.
הן יכולות להיות דיי שונות אחד מהשני וזה אפילו דברים מאוד בסיסיים.
נגיד מחקר שעבדו על תחום שעבדו עליו די הרבה בהקשר הזה.
זה נגיד קשרי משפחה. כן, יש שפות מתודה, קצת ערבית.
כן, אז יש שם הבדל. בן דוד מצד אימא ודוד מצד האבא.
מילים שבעברית זה אותו מילה. יש מילים שבהם בן דוד ואח מקבלות את אותה מילה עם הבדל המוסיקלי.
וכמובן שברוב השפות זה לא ככה. צבעים. גם בשפות שונות מחלקות צבעים בצורה אחרת.
וזה היה המון מחקר לאורך השנים. מספרים כן, תודה.
קצת צרפתית נגיד. אוקיי, לא משנה. אז פשוט היית יכול לתת דוגמה ולא רק אבל.
אבל אלה הפרמטרים שהחסימה קל לי כי כי שם זה אתה אומר.
אוקיי, זה איזשהו קונספט שמאוד ברור איך מגדירים אותו, ואני יכול ללכת ולהתעניין בשפות שונות ולהשוות.
אבל עכשיו ברור שזה רק חלק קטן. שכר נגיד.
מה עם ריהוט, חיות מחמד?
אוכל אם זה עולמות הרבה פחות מזינים מבחינת הגוף שלך אתה משווה בכלל?
אבל אתה אומר אני אעשה יותר מערך של מטבח מתודולוגיה.
איך בכלל זאת? יש את השאלה איך אפשר לשלב את הגן שלא יכול לחיות?
וזה את הלב. אני חושב על איך אפשר למקם בעצם לעשות זאת רומנטיזציה ולכן גם סטיילינג של המחקר.
מה שנקרא טופולוגיה זה המחקר שלנו, הדומה והשונה בין שפות במימד של סיכון.
זה משהו שבעצם. לעשות סיבוב של מערכת.
מערכת שלוקחת קוקוס לוקח קורס מסויים.
זה לוקח טופס בשוודית. כן נכון, אבל זה אקסטטי וזה.
עכשיו אתה אומר למערכת תציל עד כמה?
לא תרומות מסיבות פוליטיות בשתי השפות הם דומים.
עד כמה יש מילה מקבילה שאתה יודע? יש אף אחד באנגלית.
יש לך עד שבע בגיל שלך? לא יודע הכל שבסוף זה לא זוכרת.
אני כן חושב איך זה יכול להיות.
זה עובד. זה נכון, אני חושבת, אני מתחברת, אבל מסכימה שזה תואר שני.
כן, אז נגיד חבר אמיתי זה מתפרק.
לזה אתה מבין? לפי דרגת הקרבה כאילו שזה לוקח יותר משש שנים אז ממש אשמח לשמוע פחות.
כן פחות זה לא היה, אבל זה נגיד מקובל.
כן, אז זה מה שנשאר. זה תחושה קלאסית. על זה יש הרבה מה לעשות עם זה.
אז זה מה שאני רוצה. לשאול.
אתה מצליח במילים או לא מצליח להבין מה אתה רוצה?
ואז, לקראת המפגש הראשוני, בסוף איזה סיפור כזה, שיש כאלה בדרך כלל, מספרים, מספרים, ניסה לעשות מספרים משני מספרים.
זאת אומרת אתה אומר ספר ברוסית, הוא פחות אליי מחבר ובעברית פחות.
אליי קוראים המושגים 19 בספטמבר אתמול.
ברוסית או עם התרגום העיקרי שבמעשיו זו מרשה לעצמו ולאחרים.
אני רואה שאתה אומר מילה מסוימת. היא ממש הטקסט. כן כן כן, כלומר אין לי למה לדבר הזה.
נכון? ברוסית נגיד יש מילה בצבע שמן בין כחול ירוק.
זאת אומרת זאת אומרת אוקיי, אז נגיד מילה זו מילה מספיקה בהיקף מלא מילים.
כן. אז פשוט אין. אז אין קלאסיקות או נגיד באנגלית אתה עלול שחומה מול של קיר.
למרות. זאת אנגלית בהרבה.
פה זה לא זה אז זה אפשרי. אבל זה סוג של Exit אלגנטי וזו בדיוק האסטרטגיה ותכף גם ייפתר שכאילו שתי מילים חולקת אידאליזציה זאת לא מילה.
למרות שיש עוד ספרות של כל כך הרבה שפות ותרבויות.
עכשיו שבמקרה הזה חצי קבוצה בכלל.
תגיד, אתה יודע מספר אחת? מה שמעניין אותי זה מה אני.
מה צריך לעשות? בנוסף ניתן לסיים את השירות של 15 דקות.
לסיכום. רכישת התפקיד 3 שבועות.
כן. בסדר הראשון.
על השאלה הזאת אין טעם. זה בכלל משנה אם זה כזה Home או שזה כזה, אבל אני צריכה שזה יעשה לעצמי חזרה.
יש לנו שאלה. כן. בגלל שזה היה הבית שלהם שזה פשוט בושה של אגרסיה.
אתם יכולים לתאר לעצמכם שאתם עושים דברים בסוף?
אז כאילו זה לא נשמע לי הגיוני שיש הורים צריכים לחסוך במקום להעסיק אותם ולעשות.
תבין. כי זה משהו שבדרך כלל לא קורה כאן, אלא אם כן זה מתחבר לאיזה מצבים שבהם.
לא. ימים.
אני הייתי עושה את זה כל יום לפני.
אפס. סובלנות?
טוב רעיון. איזה.
אוקיי. אז ממשיכים.
בסדר. איפה היינו כאן? טוב, אז לגבי האימו בגדול.
כדי להחליט אנחנו עוד מעט נראה גם דוגמה קצת יותר מפורטת לגבי האלבום, אבל ככה מתחיל בהיי level back פופ gain.
זה חומר שאתם מכירים. האמת? כן. יש כאן מישהו או מישהו שלא זוכרים שם?
אוקיי. זה כבר חומר מאוד יסודי באמת.
וגם כאן, כמו ברשתות נוירונים אחרות, משתמשים בבק פופ Again, עבריין פה שבעצם צריך לתת עליו את הדעת, ואנחנו עוד מעט נראה דוגמה קונקרטית.
זה בעצם שבמקרה כאן, בשונה למשל לפיד פורוורד נץ.
אותם פרמטרים הם כן הם עושים, עושים בהם שימוש חוזר.
נכון, כי הרי כדי, כפי שאמרנו, כדי לחשב את Y שלוש.
כן, נגיד למשל, שהלא ספאם של שלנו מוגדר הלוואי שלוש.
כן. אז בשביל לחשב את Y שלוש אנחנו צריכים לחשב את S3?
כן, אבל כדי לחשב אבל S3 עצמה היא פונקציה.
על ידי הפעלה של הפרמטרים View של כן.
כאן כתוב H לא משנה שם זה s אז אותו דבר מצמצמים את זה.
אז H3 היא פונקציה גם של H2.
כן על ידי הפרמטרים u, אבל H2 היא פונקציה של H1.
כן בפונקציה שהפרמטרים שלה הם אותם u והיא אחד היא פונקציה של H2.
אפס שוב. על ידי אותם פרמטרים. מה זה בעצם אומר?
זה אומר שהגרף החישוב שלנו הוא כזה שבהם אותם במשקולות.
אותם הפרמטרים עוברים עוד פעם ושימוש מחדש עוד פעם ועוד פעם ועוד פעם בכל איטרציה.
כן. ולכן כדי בעצם לגזור את הרשת בעצם לגזור את הלא ספאנשן, נגיד שלוש ספאנשן שלנו.
מוגדר במושגי Y כדי לגזור את הלא ספאנשן ביחס לפרמטרים U.
אני צריך לקחת בחשבון את זה שבעצם כדי לחשב את Y שלוש יהיו אלה שלוש פעמים, נכון?
בגלל שאני צריך לראות איך? כי בעצם בעצם יש כמה.
כן, או אם נחשוב על זה ככה, נכון? מה מייצג כן מה מחשב בבק אופקי שאין לו מחשב את הגרדיאנט?
נכון ווקטור הנגזרות החלקיות, כלומר כמה שינוי בפרמטר מסוים של הרשת.
נכון? כמה שינוי פרמטר מסוים יגרום? למה? ושינוי בה.
בלוס function. נכון. אז אם אני לא ספר ישן שלי?
מוגדר על ידי y 3 אוקיי, אם אני לא ספר שלי מוגדר על ידי y 3.
ועכשיו אני רוצה לראות כמה שינוי ביו באיזשהו פרמטר ספציפי.
ביו אוקיי משפיע על הפלוס שמוגדר איכשהו כפונקציה של של y 3.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אני צריך לקחת בחשבון את זה שאם אני עכשיו הולך לשנות פה את השער הספציפי הזה במטריצה שהגיעו, השינוי הזה לא יקרה.
רק כאן הוא יקרה גם כאן וגם כאן וגם כאן.
אם אני לא אקח את זה בחשבון, אז אני אגלה שאני אולי בבעיה כי שיניתי פה את הפרמטר.
כדי שוואלה באמת המעבר מ H2 לשלוש יהיה יותר טוב.
כן, אבל לא לקחתי בחשבון את זה שאולי דפקתי בדרך את המעבר בין H1 לאשתי או בין H2 H1 בסדר וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כלומר, אני כן צריך לקחת בחשבון את זה שבאיזה שהיא צורה אני צריך לעשות roll רולה אאוט.
כן, אני צריך לעשות איזשהו בעצם לפתוח את כל הרשת, לייצר את כל הקמפיין, את הישן,
גראס ולקחת בחשבון את זה שאותם הפרמטרים משתמשים בהם עוד פעם ועוד פעם עוד ועוד פעם.
בדרך כלל מעשית לא לוקחים את זה מאז תחילת ההיסטוריה, כי פשוט זה יוצא מאוד כבד.
מחליטים על איזשהי נקודה שאחריה מפסיקים, כלומר דה פקטו חוסמים כן חוסמים את האורך של התלויות לפחות במושגי עדכון הגרדיאנט.
ואנחנו נראה עוד מעט דוגמה. אבל הרעיון הבסיסי הוא עדיין אותו Back Pop Again הטוב והמוכר.
רק שצריך לקחת בחשבון את זה שהפרמטרים משתמשים בהם עוד פעם ועוד פעם.
אתם ראיתם את הדבר הזה בימים אלו שזה ורסיה חדשה, חלק כן, חלק לא.
אוקיי, בסדר, אנחנו עוד מעט נראה דוגמה יותר קונקרטית.
אז הדוגמה הקונקרטית שאנחנו נדבר עליה זה מה שנקרא ג'נר נתיב האננס.
אוקיי, שזה יהיה השימוש העיקרי שלנו בקורס, כלומר ארמניים שבעצם משמשים כמודל שפה, או כן משהו דומה לזה.
כן, מה שקוראים לפעמים דיקור ודרמות. דיקור דר הרננדס ואנחנו נסביר מה הכוונה.
אז ניזכר ב language מודלינג נכון למושג מודלינג.
זאת הבעיה של השמה. מה בעצם עושים בלימוד שמעבירים?
בדיוק. בהינתן שאחת ההגדרות של האימוג'י מודלינג, בהינתן רישא של טקסט, אנחנו רוצים לתת התפלגות על המילה הבאה, נכון?
רוצים לתת התפלגות של המילה הבאה? אנחנו ראינו אין מודל.
כלומר מודלים קובעים איזשהו סדר נתון.
בגדול, שיטות עירוניות כן, שיטות שמבוססות על רשתות נוירונים.
הצליחו החל מאזור 2004 להראות שיפורים משמעותיים על.
על מרקוב Language Model. צריך לומר שנוהלה Language Models היו עוד קיימים לפני כן, אותו אלמנט שדיברתי עליו כבר בשנות ה 90.
חקר כל מיני. Language models. נוירון אני פשוט הביצועים שלהם היו פחות טובים במשך איזה 20 שנה.
מהם כן מהמודלים המקובלים והדבר הזה התחלף באזור 2014.
בסדר. כיום הסטייט אוף ארט הוא בדרך כלל לא הגישה שעכשיו אני אציג, אלא גישה שמבוססת על טכנולוגיה שנקראת Transformer.
שאני חושב שלפחות רובכם גם נתקלתם בה. והאמן אני צודק.
או ש. אוקיי, חלקכם זה אין בעיה. אנחנו נחזור על זה.
כן, אבל דייה צרה לשעתה אנחנו נדבר עליהם בהמשך הקורס.
אבל כל הדברים האלה הם דברים מאוד אפקטיביים והשאלה האם הטרנספורמר פופולרי יותר או אריק הגישה רק טורנט פופולרי יותר, או אולי שילוב שלהם.
כמו שיש גם עבודות כאלה, אני חושב שעוד. כן נכון.
נכון, המטוטלת עוד כנראה תמשיך להתנועע, להתנועע,
אבל כך או כך הנושא שלנו עכשיו הוא נדבר על language models ונתחיל דווקא מה הפשוטות ביותר, הפשוטות ביותר הם בעצם לא.
Language model שהם באיזושהי צורה מר קובי. אז מה הכוונה?
הכוונה היא שגם עוד עוד לפני שבעצם אנחנו מדברים על ארמנים שמבצעים Language מודלינג, אפשר להסתכל בוורסיה יותר בסיסית,
שגם היא בהחלט קיימת, שמה שהיא אומרת זה שבגדול אני מעריך שפחות או יותר כן מתקיימת אי תלות.
כן, אי תלות מותנה. כלומר, אני הולך להניח מין סוג של הנחה.
מרקוביץ בעצם הנחה מרקוביץ, אבל להציע מודל נוירוני שחוזה את המילה הבאה ולא מודל שמבוסס על Hard Candy Script.
אוקיי, אז שוב אנחנו מניחים איזשהו פיקסלים window בסדר איזשהו גודל הקשר קבוע נתון במקרה כאן כן באורך באורך n גדול,
ואנחנו בעצם מנסים לשערך את ההתפלגות של המילה הבאה.
בהינתן בין המילים הקודמות, מה זה אומר על הנייר?
אז בגדול אפשר לחשוב על זה. פשוט קביעת דיקציה. כן, בעת דיקציה אני עכשיו רוצה לחזות את דאבליו.
טי. בהינתן הראשה אני מניח והנחת אמר קוביות.
אוקיי, דאבל מוטי בהינתן כל הרעש עמיד דאבליו אחד זה שווה פחות בקירוב מספיק טוב לצרכי להסתברות של דאבל נתיב.
בהינתן שלושת המילים הקודמות, נגיד שגודל בקונטקסט של שלוש מה אני עושה?
בגדול אני לוקח וכל אחת מהמילים האלה אני הופך לווקטור שנקרא אם Padding.
שוב זוכרים. אם אתם לא מכירים את המושג לא נתקלתם בו.
תחשבו על זה פשוט כי וואן הופ וקטור שמייצג את המילה אנחנו נלמד בשבוע הבא גם שיטות יותר אפקטיביות אבל בגדול מייצג כל מילה וקטור.
כן, הדבר הזה בעצם נכנס לאיזשהו פיד forward נט נכון?
אם כל אחד מהווה וקטורים האלה הוא בגודל D. כן, כל אחד מהם וקטורים שמייצגים את המילים בגודל D.
אז יש לי פה עכשיו כשאני משרשרת אותם נכון input וקטור במימד.
שלוש די יפה. כן, שלוש די. ואני ממפה אותו לאיזשהו עידן לירקן, לאיזשהו עיצוב פנימי של הרשת שהוא מאיזשהו מימד שסימנתי אותו.
DASH פה בסדר, אולי יש כמה שכבות כאלה בסדר ואז אני כן אז יש לי, אז אני עושה את זה כמה פעמים.
יש איזושהי מטריצת משקולות? דאבליו נגיד אוקיי, שהיא מעבירה אותי מ השכבה מאה protection לירקן בדימוס.
להלן נייר עוד מטריצה יואו שמעבירה אותי מהממד הפנימי של הרשת למימד אוצר המילים והדבר הזה
אני עושה הוספת מקס ומקבל וקטור כן של מספרים חיוביים שמסתכם לאחד וכל אחד מהקורסים להטות.
אני מפרש אותו כי ההסתברות שהמילה הזאת תופיע.
אוקיי, אז יש לי וקטור בגודל אוצר המילים שהוא output של soft מקס.
וכן הערה הקואורדינטות הראשונה זה ההסתברות שאר דבר כי המילה הבאה והוא קורדינציה 42 זה ההסתברות שפי שזה המילה הבאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה עד נגיד זברה.
אוקיי, אז זאת ארכיטקטורה פשוטה.
כאן זה בגדול פשוט הפלטפורמות כן, מה שנקרא לפעמים ml, P, מולטי לידר, סקטור נפולי connected.
כל הדברים האלה עוברים אותו דבר. פשוט רשת נוירונים פשוטה שבעצם היא עדיין מממשת language model ברקוביץ אבל זה כבר לא ברקוביץ שמבוסס על n גרמים,
אלא זמר קובי, שמבוסס על בעצם חישוב מהיר אונליין.
אוקיי, עכשיו למה שנעשה זה כן.
אם זה עדיין רשת מרקוביץ בסדר. אז למה טרה כל כך כן?
יש לנו כבר לשתות מן קוביות. למדנו עליהם. אתם יודעים איך לעבוד איתם?
מה עכשיו? אני מכניס פה את הנייר על הנייר עד מרקוב מודל.
אז כן, איזה ערך מוסף הם בכלל נותנים לי?
אז הרעיון הוא שהערך המוסף שהם נותנים זה שלפחות עקרונית הם יכולים.
לפחות עקרונית הם יכולים להכליל בין מילים.
כן, מה שנקרא לקסיקון General זה יש כן. אז מה הרעיון?
נכון? אז הרעיון הוא שאם קודם לכן נכון, אם קודם לכן מה הדרך שבה חזיתי?
מה התפלגות המילים שמופיעות אחרי for all? ועל כן נגיד אם יש לי גם מודל אני הולך.
בודק את כל המקרים שבהם מופיע בטריינינג set שלי for all.
זה נכון? בודק איזה מילים מגיעות אחרי זה, מחשב את ההתפלגות האמפירית, מפעיל על זה, סודר את שמאל,
מפעיל על זה בקוף מודל וכל השיטות החלקה לסוגיהם שאתם אוהבים להשתמש קני זרמי ודברים אחרים.
ואני מקבל בעצם את ההתפלגות של ההתפלגות של המילה הבאה.
הדבר הזה, כפי שראינו, אין בו יותר מדי הכללה פיסיקלית.
כן, החוויה לפסיקה לא מאוד מוגבלת. אז למשל אם ראיתי כן למשל I have to make sure that I can't get speed.
אז אם ראיתי את זה בעצם הדבר הזה לא ישמש לי evidence.
כנראה כן, לפחות לא באופן ישיר לזה שגם dog Speed הוא שלשה סבירה.
כן, כי אולי get fed, אבל דווקא בקיץ הם מופיעים באותם הקשרים.
אז אולי גם דוקס Get Speed?
גם הוא צריך לקבל קצת עידוד. כן, מזה שהופיע Cats Get fed ונהפך.
אין גם language models באמת יחשבו על זה כשני פרמטרים שונים.
אתה יכול פשוט תשמע את אשתי. הסתברויות שונות במודל שכל אחת מהם אולי קצת תתרום לשנייה בגלל החלקות, אבל זה יהיה בשוליים.
לא נראה לי מודל כן, ואנחנו נדבר על זה שוב יותר בשיעור הבא, אבל אמר על Language model הוא מסוגל באיזושהי צורה לבצע הכללה.
לפחות זאת השאיפה. למה? כי בעצם אני יש לי כאן איזשהי רשת נוירונים?
כן, ואני אומר בשאיפה רשת נוירונים הזאת כן, בגלל שהיא עוברת דרך איזשהו הדולר.
ואם אני אצליח לשערך אם באמת הלמידה שלי תהיה כזאת שאדם ומלוויו האלה ילמדו בצורה לפחות נגיד את דאבליו אלמנט בצורה טובה.
אז מה שיקרה זה שדור וקאט בסופו של Dogs, Get Speed וקצת Get Speed יקבלו ייצוג דומה בעידן Large.
כן, למרות שאם בדייג שלהם הוא שונה בהיטלר אולי הם ייראו דומים.
למה הם יראו דומים? כי זה אולי מקטין את הלא ספאנשן.
כן, בגלל שזה תורם לי להכללה ואולי הרשת תהיה מסוגלת.
אנחנו לא יודעים. כן, אבל אם נחזיק אצבעות ונתפלל אולי.
שתצליח ללמוד שבאמת אין גורמים האלה קשורים ולכן צריך לתת להם בית דין.
חשוב כאמור עוד על זה בשיעור בשיעור הבא, אבל זה כבר יתרון שרשת כזאת עשויה לתת, למרות שהיא עדיין בתקופת.
כן. אם היינו כבר בגיל. כן, זה נכון להשתמש בדבר הזה באינטרנט לפני כן, אבל הוא כבר שם.
כן, אבל. אבל תשים לב שכאן אתה צודק שאם מראש היינו יודעים שכלבים כן,
זה שאלה מצוינת שכאילו שאם מראש היינו יודעים שחתולים וכלבים הם דומים מבחינת איזה מילים הם מופיעות אחריהם או משהו כזה,
אז אתה צודק, היינו יכולים להשתמש בזה גם באם, גם models וכן הלאה.
אבל כאן הרעיון הוא שאנחנו לא מניחים את זה אפריורית.
כן, כאן הרעיון. או שבעצם אנחנו אומרים שמה שאנחנו אומרים זה שהרשת היא בעצם צריכה איכשהו לייצג את הטריק הזה.
כן, איכשהו לייצג את השלישייה הזאת על ידי וקטור מממד מתאים, לא משנה מה כן.
אז עכשיו כל השלישיות, כל מאה אלף בשלישית שלישיות, נגיד שלי, כולם הולכות לקבל איזשהו וקטור.
כן הולכות לעבור עם בנים ואז הולכות להיות מכפלות ודאבל יו ואולי נון לינארית, לא משנה מה.
אחרי שהם יעברו איזושהי פונקציה מסובכת הם כולם יתמכו לאותו וקטור ממימד 200.
עכשיו הרעיון של נכון של רשתות נוירונים זה שבעצם אתה אומר אתה אומר אני אגדיר את הלא שפם כנכון.
זאת אומרת, אני אגיד מה אני רוצה מהם, ואם אני אחזיק אצבעות והמזל ישחק לידי,
אז הרשת תלמד שבעצם כדי למזער את הלופוס כדי לייצג וקטורים, שבעצם כדאי לה שהייצוג הזה יהיה אפקטיבי.
כן, עכשיו מה זה ייצוג אפקטיבי?
ייצוג שמייצג שתי שלשות שיכולות להופיע אחרי אותם מילים פחות או יותר כשני וקטורים ממש שונים, הוא כנראה לא ייצוג מאוד יעיל, כי סך הכל המימדים מוגבלים.
יש לך 200 מימדים, זה מה שיש. כנראה לא מאוד יעיל לייצג.
יש הרבה שלשות שונות שכולם פחות או יותר יש להם את אותה סטטיסטיקות תופעה כי הווקטורים שהם לגמרי שונים במרחב אתה רוצה לייצג אותם בצורה דומה,
כך שהם כן יקבלו פרטי קצת דומות. תוך שימוש בכל שימוש אפקטיבי בקן בכפס שיש לך לאכסון באותם לאותם 200 מימדים, אז כאילו אז זה לפחות תקווה שיכול.
שוב אנחנו נדון בשיעור הבא יותר לעומק. למה אולי לחשוב שהתקווה כזאת עשויה להתממש?
מה בשפה גורם לנו לחשוב שאולי תקוות כאלה יכולות להתממש?
אבל היא לפחות אומרת, לפחות עקרונית, יש לרשת את היכולת לבצע את ההכללה הזאת.
אם היא למדה עם משקולות מספיק טובות שבאמת היא הפכה אותם לדיקטטורים לא בסדר.
כן, עוד שאלות. בסדר.
יפה. אז ככה. זה רק כדי להגיד שלא נץ.
מעבר לרקורד נטיעות, אולי זה רעיון טוב להשתמש בנוער נץ, ללמד את שמעון דרלינג והיו באמת עבודות כאלה.
אבל מה שהריקוד מאולץ כמובן נותנות לנו ומראש זאת הסיבה שכן שהלכנו לכיוון הזה זה בעצם מה שהן עושות.
טוב זה שאנחנו לא צריכים להגדיר את המימד, כן את הגודל של הקונטקסט בצורה קבועה מוקשה מראש,
אלא זה יהיה משהו אדפטיבי שהוא בשאיפה ילמד פונקציה שתוכל לקחת בחשבון כל מיני דברים חשובים, גם אם הם קרו הרחק הרחק אחורה.
כן, אז זה הארכיטקטורה הבסיסית של ריקון מלט.
כן, ארכיטקטורה סך הכל מאוד פשוטה. יש לנו את HS כן או אס אפס.
קראנו לו קודם. לא משנה, זה אותו דבר יש לנו. אנחנו בעצם בכל שלב מזינים לרשת את כן את המילה שמופיעה באותו מקום.
תזכרו, יש לנו טריינינג Data. נכון שהוא בעצם הקורפוסים שאנחנו מאמנים עליהם.
כן, אותם קורפוסים שבעזרתם אנחנו משייכים את הפרמטרים או אוספים סטטיסטיקות או לא משנה איך שתקראו לזה, אז יש לנו את המילים האלה.
אנחנו כל פעם מזינים את כך וכך מילים הראשונות נגיד Students Commander, נגיד עכשיו אנחנו תשע באורך ארבע.
בסדר, אנחנו מחשבים לכל אחד מהם.
אנחנו ממפים אותו לווקטור שלו. כן, לווקטור שמתאים לו מקבלים איזה שהוא ייצוג סדרה של וקטורים נכון X 4 ועכשיו אנחנו.
יש לנו איזשהי רשת רקורסיבית? כן, איזשהי פונקצייה רקורסיה אנטי שגם היא רשת קטנה או גדולה.
במקרה הפשוט כאן קטנה שיש לה פרמטרי מטריצות ובעיה string.
המטריצות האלה לוקחות את האם בדיוק של המילה הנוכחית ואת ההיטל סטייט.
כן, את הייצוג של הרישא של השלב הקודם ומייצרות ממנו את העידן States של המצב הבא.
ובסופו של דבר, כשאנחנו רוצים לחזות מה המילה הבאה, אנחנו לוקחים את ה 14.
כן, את הייצוג של הרישא של ארבעת המילים הראשונות, מפעילים עליהם שוב פונקציה אפינית בסוף Max ומקבלים בעצם איזה שהיא כניסתו גרמה של הסתברויות.
אולי הוא יתן בהסתברות גבוהה לבורקס בלפטופ וכאלה.
זה נגיד דוגמאות שאולי היינו מצפים. אוקיי, זה ארכיטקטורה מאוד בסיסית.
זאת הארכיטקטורה הבסיסית של ARM. פשוט ROM.
הכי ונילה הכי סטנדרטי אל מה שקראנו לו קודם אל מנאר עינן ואפשר לנסות להשתמש בה בגדול.
מסתבר שעד כדי כל מיני הסתייגויות שאני תכף אדבר עליהם, החל מ סדר גודל שלפני 15 שנה התחום הזה התחיל לצבור תאוצה.
בערך מאזור 2004 הוא כבר הפך להיות כן המושל בכיפה ברוב המקרים, והלך והשתלט כמעט לחלוטין.
אני חושב בחמש שנים כן של סוף העשור הקודם.
כן, אותה ארכיטקטורה בסיסית,
לפעמים עם קצת שינויים וההבדל העיקרי באמת מהפיד פורוורד אלן שאלנו קודם זה שעכשיו אנחנו יכולים לקחת בחשבון הקשרים באורך באורך כלשהו?
כן, ובשאיפה לאמן את הרשת, ככה שבאמת ה דאבליו הזה ישמור את האינפורמציה הרלוונטית ויזרוק את האינפורמציה לא רלוונטית כך שנוכל בסוף באמצעות HDR באמת
לקחת בחשבון את כל המילים הרלוונטיות שקדמו ולשכוח כי משהו צריך לשכוח כי יש לנו כפס מוגבל וכן טריף עצים באורך לא מוגבל.
אז לשכוח את מה שאין צורך לשמור לצורך תחזית של המילה הבאה.
בנאדם חשוב בהקשר הזה זה תומס מיק או לוב ויש כאן קישור לתזה שלו מ 2011.
אוקיי. בסדר, וזה שובל לא ספאנשן.
אז איך אנחנו במקרה הזה עכשיו? סוף סוף אנחנו מגיעים לדוגמה קונקרטית לאימון.
איך אנחנו מאמנים רשת? אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון הלא הסטנדרטי זה מה שנקרא Chosen to פלוס שאני מניח שאתם מכירים.
אתם זוכרים כולם שלחזור מה זה אומר?
מי שמשלם אוקיי, נכון, אז זה הדבר הכי סטנדרטי שהיה לא הכי סטנדרטי שמשתמשים בו עם Soft מקס פשוט מינוס לוג ההסתברות של התשובה הנכונה.
אוקיי, איך עושים את זה? בגדול משתמשים בשיטה ומשתמשים בגישה שנקראת three four sing.
כן, שמה שזה. אומר זה שבעצם אנחנו לוקחים את השרשרת.
כן, נגיד שזאת נגיד זה התחלה של הקורפוס שלנו.
אוקיי, או של הטקסט הנוכחי The students open dark seems,
ואנחנו מייצרים ממנו את דוגמאות האימון זה בהינתן מחרוזת ריקה students בהינתן מחרוזת ריקה ו open.
בהינתן מחרוזת ריקה זה, זאת אומרת כל מילה.
היא בעצם הופכת להיות דוגמת אימון בהינתן הרישא שקדמה לה.
בסדר. אז בעצם עכשיו מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה להגדיר זה בעצם אני לא SIM שלנו Yo כן, אלא סלפי דיקציה ראשונה.
זה יהיה קרוז אנטרופי של הפרי. דיקציה כזאת כן.
ומה שמסומן קנוי כובע אחד כן.
כן, אז זה יהיה Cross אנטרופי של וואי כובע אחד אפשר לסמן אותו.
כן, אחד תטא הקוסם copy של דבליו, כובע שתיים וכן הלאה.
ומהו אותו גיי? לא משנה i או chat זה פשוט המילה הנכונה, כלומר המילה האמיתית שמופיע בקורפוס במקום עטים ועוד אחד ההסתברות.
אני מסתכל עליה ואני מסתכל בווקטור העודפות של השלב הבא בעצם לווקטור ה output של המשקולות שאמורות לייצג את המילה t ועוד אחד,
כלומר האאוטפיט בשלב טי ואת ההסתברות שהוא נותן למילה הנכונה, זאת שבאמת תופיע בקורפוס מינוס לוג של זה בסדר הזה.
הקורס. אנטרופי לא סטנדרטי ואני רוצה לסחור על כולם כדי לקבל את כדי לקבל את הבוס.
עד כאן בסדר, כן. אז אה כן, והמילה האמיתית זה בעצם האיקס טי ועוד אחד.
כן, כי בעצם מה הוא נגיד לא היה לי פה X טי ועוד אחד.
אתה מתכוון במוטציה? כן. שמאל?
אוקיי, אז זאת התשובה. אז אם אני לא מסתכל אני מוחק את זה.
מה זה Y קובטי? איזה יצור מתמטי הוא נכון?
וקטור של בעצם שמשחק סליחה נכון של ערכים חיוביים זה האאוטפיט של אסף מקס בשלב טי.
נגיד. אם זה ארבע אז זו תהיה כן ההסתברות איזושהי שוגרה מעל שכוללת איזושהי הסתברות להגזמה,
והסתברות, לפטופ והסתברות, לנוט בוקס, והסתברות, להרצאה ועכשיו מה שאין לי.
אז אני מסתכל על כל הווקטור הזה באורך אוצר המילים, ואני מציץ על המילה הבאה שעוד לא נכנסתי לרשת.
נכון? ואני רואה אהה הזאת זה רמז. ועכשיו אני הולך ובוחר את הקואורדינציה מתוך הווקטור.
וואי כובע הסופר סקפטי שמתאימה למילה Example שהוא איקס תיבות אחד בסדר.
נראה לי שאני צריך לחזור על זה. אוקיי, עוד שאלות.
אוקיי. כן, אז למדתם על פיצ'ר פרשינג והיום סתם.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו לענות על השאלה.
זה פשוט ההגדרה של פיצ'ר פרשינג. מה שאמרתי עכשיו שאתה לוקח שרשרת ובעצם אתה אתה.
אתה חושב עליה כסדרה של כל מנה היא בעיה, דיקציה לכשעצמה שהיא לחזות את המילה בהינתן הראשון.
כלומר, אם יש לי חמש מילים יש לי פה. בעצם אני חושב על זה.
15 טריינינג example זה בהינתן ריק students בהינתן open בהינתן The student וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן, למה זה נקרא פיצ'ר Force?
בהמשך הקורס אנחנו נבין ונבין מה זה ולמה.
זה לא תמיד רעיון כזה טוב, אבל סך הכל גם רעיון די סביר.
זאת אומרת, נבין את המגבלות ועל היתרונות בהמשך הקורס.
בסדר, כן, אז כנל. כן, אני לוקח פה את הנושא.
כל פעם אני מציב ואני מקפל את לא screen לכל אחד.
לכל אחת מהפונקציות כאן זה יהיה נגטיב לוגו פרופ של open נגטיב, לא פרופ שוטר נגטיב, לא פופ של Example וכן הלאה.
בסדר עכשיו. באופן עקרוני, כפי שאמרנו, כדי לחשב את הגרדיאנט, בעצם כדי לחשב את הגרדיאנט בארמנים, אני צריך ללכת ולעשות רול back עד תחילת השרשרת שלי.
נכון, ועם הקורפוס שלי הוא פשוט ספר שמכיל לא יודע מאה אלף מילים.
אז לכאורה אני צריך לחשב את ההשפעה של מאה מילה הראשונה בספר.
את ההשפעה שלה על המילה ה 100 אלף. כן, וזה יהיה יקר אז דה פקטו לוקחים.
חותכים את זה לחתיכות כמו משפטים פסקאות.
לא משנה שאלה כמה יש לכם, אז זה בעצם מה שהדבר הזה רוצה לומר.
ועכשיו אנחנו רוצים לעשות back Properties. נכון, אנחנו רוצים לחשב את הגרדיאנט כדי שנוכל לעשות צעדי עדכון בכיוון כן, בכיוון, בכיוון הגרדיאנט.
אז איך עושים את זה? אז בוא נסתכל על איזשהו תקן.
אז איך מחושב אותו? ג'יי תטא כן, גיי תטא הוא בעצם נכון.
משהו שהוא פונקציה של Wait, שהוא עצמו פונקציה של HD שהיא עצמה פונקציה של HD מינוס אחד שיהיה צבע פונקציה של x מינוס 2 וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נכון, זה בדיוק מה שאמר שזה כל הזמן אות ההפעלה.
כלומר אם אני רוצה עכשיו, בהנחה שהפונקציה רקורסיבית, שני הפרמטרים שלה זה Watch.
כן, אלה הפרמטרים שנגיד זה היה פונקציה אפינית בסדר שמעבירה אותי שבעצם קובעת את הפונקציה הקורינתי.
אז בעצם אותו אז Watch פה מופיע בגרף החישוב הרבה פעמים כן, אפילו חילקתי למשפטים בסדר, אז זה כבר T הוא לא מאה אלף T הוא רק שלושים.
זה עדיין מופיע די הרבה פעמים. איך נראה לו השפה שלו?
אז בגדול, מה שמפעילים את כלל השרשרת, מה שמוצאים זה שהדבר הזה בעצם שווה לגזור את בעצם מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה לגזור את.
לגזור את T פעם אחת ביחס ל.
שנייה. אני צריך להגיד את זה בצורה אוקיי, אולי נעשה את זה כאן זה יהיה יותר ברור.
כן, בגדול, מה שזה, מה שזה יוצא זה שאנחנו צריכים לגזור את.
ג'יי. טי ביחס לדאבל UH.
ואנחנו צריכים, אבל בעצם אנחנו. צריך לחשוב שנייה איך לנסח.
אז בואו אני אראה את זה בדוגמה זה יהיה לי יותר ברור מאשר מס הכנסה אחר.
אז בוא נסתכל על איזושהי דוגמה ונבין מה בעצם קורה כאן.
אז אז ככה. אז הנה דוגמה קלה כן, איזושהי רשת קוונטית מאוד פשוטה.
כובע שווה ל סיגמה או שלוש דאבליו אפס.
אוקיי, את זה הוא שלוש. כן, דבליו דבליו אפס בסדר והוא שלוש הוא הפעלה של הפונקציה.
הרקורד סטייט כן של הפונקציה הרלוונטית שכתובה כאן.
כן, הוא בעצם יהיה פונקציה של O2, או אם כאן זה בעצם ההיטל סטייט.
כן, מה שעובר משלב לשלב. אז יהיה לי O2 כפול weight או 1 כפול דאבל UH.
זה מה שהיא חושבת. הוא שתיים או אחד זה הוא אפס כפול דבליו אייץ וכן הלאה.
והוא אפס. זה המצב ההתחלתי. כן שאולי הוא רנדומלי או משהו.
עכשיו איך בעצם אני רוצה לפרוס את גרף החישוב?
בסדר, אני רוצה לפרוס את גרף החישוב. אז ככה זה בעצם נראה.
ה lose הוא פונקציה של הוואי קובע נכון של הפרדה קצה של הרשת.
על מה הוואי קובע? זה מסתמך בסדר, מסתמך על דאבליו אפס.
כן, כלומר דבליו אפס.
זה פחות יעניין אותנו, כי זה לא מה שאנחנו רוצים לגזור. לכן זה אחד מהפרמטרים.
כן, אני אזכיר לכם זה הפרמטר. כן, דאבליו אפס זה כאילו הפרמטר שבעזרתו לוקחים את היידן סטייט ומכפילים אותו כדי לקבל את הפרדיגמה.
אבל מה שבעיקר מעניין זה פחות משנה לנו כי הוא מופיע.
הוא מופיע רק פעם אחת בחישוב החלק הבעייתי מבחינתנו זה הדאבל With.
נכון שמופיע בכל שלב של החישוב עוד פעם ועוד פעם, אז בעצם אני צריך לפרוס את זה.
אז אני אומר וואי, כובע הוא בעצם פונקציה של או שלוש של העידן סטייט השלישי.
נכון, זה פשוט או שלוש איזשהו פונקציה שהיא של או שלוש הזה שתלויה בפרמטרים דאבליו אפס.
ככה אני מחשבת Y קובע וככה אני מחשבת הלעוס. אוקיי, הוא שלוש.
הוא עצמו בעצם מחושב על ידי איזה שהוא חישוב שתלוי גם באיקס שלוש פחות רלוונטי עכשיו ובאיזה שהם עוד פרמטרים UI שגם פחות רלוונטי עכשיו.
אבל מה שכן חשוב לנו אם מסתמך על Watch כן על הפרמטרים של הפונקציה הרי קוונטית יחד עם O2 נכון?
אז הוא לוקח את O2 את הפרמטרים של הפונקציה הרפורמית ועושה איתה משהו.
כן, ספציפית מכפיל אותה במקרה הזה אבל לא משנה בסדר או שתיים.
הוא גם תלוי בכל מיני דברים, אבל הוא גם תלוי באור אחד ודאבל UH כאן שוב בפונקציה רקורסיבית,
בפרמטרים שלה ובעיבוד שמזין אותה או אחד כנל תלוי ב או אפס שהוא אפשר לחשוב עליו סתם כמה שהוא רנדומלי או לא.
לא בדיוק. כן, הוא ממילא מופיע רק פעם אחת, אז זה פחות בעייתי לנו.
ושוב with אוקיי, אז עכשיו בעצם המצב שלנו הוא כזה שאם אני רוצה לגזור את הלוס function שמפיק Watch, אז בוא נראה איך נראה.
איך זה נראה לפי כלל השרשרת. כן, אז מה שאני צריך לעשות בעצם כן.
אז מה שבעצם אני צריך לעשות זה איכשהו לקחת בחשבון את שלושת המסלולים האלה.
כן, את זה שבעצם בגרף החישוב שלי Watch נכנס שלוש פעמים.
אוקיי. אם אתם זוכרים את למטה על פה, כמו במקרה שיש כמה מסלולים שמובילים לחישוב, לא, זה תמיד יהיה לכם עץ הגרף החישוב.
אוקיי, בסדר סביר.
Have to take my wait for it. כי אני מניח שאם לא למדתם את זה אני יכול ללמד את זה, אבל אז כדאי שאני אלמד את זה בנפרד.
לא למדתם אז על כל השרשרת הרב מימדי? לא, הרבה כן וכל שאר הדברים.
יעקוביאן אוקיי הקוריאנית. אז אולי נעשה אחרי זה סקר אם אנשים רוצים ללמוד את הכל, את הגרסה הכללית של פגישה.
אבל ברור שבאופן כללי, אם אתם רוצים לחשב גרדיאנט, לפעמים אתם נתקלים במצב שבו Watch שלכם מופיעות מופיעים כמה פעמים.
נכון, זה בדיוק המצב שלנו ולכן במושגי back פרופ יש לנו בעצם כמה מסלולים.
נכון, יש לנו כמה מסלולים שמשתמשים באותם פרמטרים.
כן, אותה אותו input אותו אותם פרמטרים זה לא אותם פרמטרים שהמדד מופיעים כמה פעמים
הדרך הנכונה לפי כלל השרשרת הרב מימדי שאני לא אלמד אותו עכשיו אלא בעקבות הסקר,
אחליט אם ללמד אותו בכלל או שתצטרכו זה Take my wait for it.
מה שבעצם אומר זה. שאתם צריכים לסחוב על פני המסלולים האלה.
אוקיי, זאת אומרת, אתם פעם אחת צריכים להסתכל על.
בעצם אתם אומרים אוקיי, אם היה לכם אתם צריכים לחשב כאילו את המסלול כאילו לעשות back to.
לדאבל A שזה כאילו ה O2 הוא הגיע כאילו O2 הוא לא פונקציה של Watch ואז לקחת ולעשות בעצם ולגזור את Watch לפי המסלול הזה כן,
כלומר תוך התעלמות מה כן הייתי מכין ואחרי זה לפי המסלול הזה ואז לסכום על שלושת המכפלות האלה.
נכון, כל בית פרובו בעצם מכפלה של האירועים בצלעות שהמסלול עובר בהם אז פשוט צריך לסכום על המסלולים.
והסיבה לזה היא בדיוק הסיבה שהם כן.
הסיבה לזה היא בדיוק הסיבה שהנגזרת החלקית של הלא ספאם שם ביחס לדאבל UH ביחס לפרמטרים של הפונקציה הקוונטית,
היא בעצם סכימה על פני הדגים ב כנהגים השונים לאורך השרשרת, כאילו כדי לגזור את הג'י.
טי. כן, כדי לגזור את T, כלומר את הלא ספאנשן בנקודה התאית, כלומר הפרי דיקציה לגבי מהי המילה התיבות אחד.
מה שאני צריך לעשות זה יוצא שקול לגזור את לגזור את כל ה game לאורך הדרך.
כן, את כל הפרטים קצת לאורך הדרך. לפי אותו דאבליו H כן, כאילו בנפרד, כאילו הם היו עומדים בפני עצמם תוכי ולסחור ולסחור על כולם.
לא משנה, לא נוכיח את זה כי זה ידרוש חומר שלא למדתם אבל בסדר אבל זה בגדול.
Back population זה דברים. זה מאוד דומה למה שאתם למדתם אבל צריך לסכום על כמה מסלולים.
טוב infectious influence אמרנו?
אז אוקיי, אז יש לנו רשת כזאת. איך אנחנו זה היא אמורה להיות מודל שפה?
איך אנחנו מייצרים איתה? כן. איך אנחנו מבצעים אינפלציה?
אנחנו מבצעים עסק? כן. איך אנחנו מבצעים פרי? דיקציה? אז כאן זה קצת שאלה, כי בעצם יש כל מיני דרכים לעשות את זה.
אנחנו כבר לא בעולם המכובד. אוקיי, אנחנו כבר לא בעולם המקומי, אז כבר לא נצליח כנראה למצוא את הסדרה המצטברת ביותר.
כן, את הסדרה שמקבלת את המקסימום. הסתברות מבין כל הסדרות נכון?
למה? כי בעצם יש לנו פה מרחב אקספוננציאלי נכון של String עם אפשריים.
נגיד אתם מחפשים את ה string סביר ביותר באורך 20.
אוקיי, את המשפט הבא סביר ביותר.
אז יש כגודל אוצר המילים בחזקת 20 אפשרויות נכון ואין לנו את המרק קוביות שתאפשר לנו לעשות ויתר או מעין dynamic programming או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
כן, אז אנחנו יכולים להיות גרידי. נכון, זה דרך אחת כל פעם להגיד אוקיי, מה המילה הבאה הכי סבירה?
אין בעיה, אני אעשה. Forward pass הראה נכון?
מקבל פה התפלגות שקראנו לה וואי. אני אקבל פה התפלגות שנקראת Y, קובע סופר סקריפט.
אחד כזה ניקח את המהות של האתר הכי סביר.
כן, את הארגון Max, נגיד Max ואחרי זה אני אבוא ונסתכל על משהו A2 קוביות צילי בסדר, אני כך שם את הדבר הזה.
הוא לאו דווקא רעיון טוב, כי מכל מיני סיבות, אבל אחת מהן היא גרידי, הוא לא לאו דווקא אופטימלי.
נכון? כי בדיוק מסיבות שרידיו, ככלל, בהרבה מקרים לא אופטימליים נכון, בחרתי משהו.
התחייבתי למילה הזאת בשלב הרביעי, אבל איכשהו כן.
אם הייתי בוחר במילה קצת פחות סבירה בשלב הרביעי, אז פתאום זה היה מאפשר לי איזה שרשרת הרבה יותר סבירה להמשיך ממנה הלאה, אבל הייתי מגלה את זה רק אחר כך.
כן, כרגיל, אז אין לנו כאן שום הבטחה שזה רעיון טוב.
לפעמים מה שעושים זה לא לוקחים את המודל. דוגמים כן ולא דוגמים את המילה על כל הדברים האלה.
אנחנו נדבר בהמשך, אבל בגדול חשוב לדעת שברגע שמה שחשוב לי, בעיקר בשלב הזה להגיד, זה שמרגע שעזבנו את העולם המר קובי כבר אין טוויטר.
בי כבר אין אקזקט Influence.
אתם יכולים להיות גרידי. אם אתם יכולים לדגום, אתם יכולים לעשות שלל דברים אחרים שמגיע להם בהמשך הקורס.
אבל אין לכם הבטחות לגבי עד כמה הדבר הזה טוב ביחס למודל השפה הנלמד.
שאלות עד כאן. אוקיי, יפה מה שנלמד אחרי ההפסקה.
מה שנגיע אליו אחרי ההפסקה זה בעצם הנושא של מה שנקרא אקספלורר, דינג ונשים פריידיי.
הסכם שבו נתקלתם או לא נתקל.
מי כן נתקל אי פעם במושג הזה? אוקיי, אחלה רובכם.
מי לא נתקל במוסר? אוקיי, יפה, אז אתם מכירים את זה, אז זו תהיה חזרה קצרה על הסיפור הזה.
ואז אנחנו ננסה קצת להבין איפה הבעיה הזאת של ונשיג טקסט עם גרדיאנט עשויה להפריע לנו כשאנחנו חושבים על
מודלי שפה מבוססי RNA ונזכיר במילה או שתיים מה בכל זאת עשו ועושים כדי כן כדי להתגבר על הבעיה הזאת?
אוקיי, אז נחזור אחרי ההפסקה. עכשיו זה.
לא. אז באופן כללי כשאתה מבצע אז תסתכל למטה הביטחון.
אתה מסתכל על. רגע. תראה, בוא ניקח דוגמה פשוטה.
בוא ניקח דוגמה פשוטה אוקיי. בוא נגיד שיש לך מטרה טובה.
חישוב נורא פשוט, אפילו. לאו דווקא רומני. אבל כן, יש לך חשד שמה שהוא עושה אז נגיד.
נגיד שיש לך איזשהם קישוטים בבית ויש לך איזה בית מחשבים יחסית בסיסי הגיוני.
יש לך מטבחים ברווח מסביב הרווח ואז.
והדבר הזה בתכלס זה C.
כן, הם עוברים מחברה שאני יודע שאתה יודע.
עכשיו אתה רוצה למסור את זה ביחס לחיילי צהל כסטנדרט החוקי.
החישוב הזה בא לכם? על רקע הגרף הזה של הפונקציה שאני מייצגת הדבר הזה?
אז המפרט של אס ביחס מה היא שווה?
אז פה למעשה שנייה לפני זה התוצר זה איך כן בדיוק התרומה של כל העבודה שלה.
אז מה הנגזרת של F ביחס? אז הנגזרת של f ביחס ל n היא בעצם אתה יודע, אתה יכול לחשב את זה מראש.
אתה מבין כאן אפשר לחשב. אז מה שיש לנו זה רק של A השלישי ועוד בריבוע כל מה שזה שווה לשלוש.
בסוף זה בריבוע כפול. דיוויד כן, אבל זה קצת מוזר לפינה הזאת.
כן, פשוט עצרתי את סיבוב. כן, הייתי יכול לבקש לעשות אוקיי.
אבל עכשיו בוא נסתכל על זה מנקודת מבט של פקטור.
כן, אז a כפול c. מה הנגזרת של זה ביחס?
מה הנגזרת? הזרע? הצלע הזאת? מה גזרת של זה ביחס ל.
ביחסים? זה דבר בסיסי.
כן. מה אני סרט של עשיתי את השואה?
כן. אז עכשיו בעצם מה יש לך כאן?
יש לך כאן מסלול אחד? יש לנו כאן שני מסלולים. עכשיו נכון שמובילים בין ה לבין התוצאה.
כן, זה וזה. שזה אחד.
זה המכפלה של הגוף שני בריבוע והשני המכפלה שלהם.
הוא פשוט רצה לפצל את המסלול הזה.
מצד ימין זה בעצם מצד השופט. כן, זהו בדיוק כאילו אתה כאילו אתה גוזר את זה כאילו אין שום דבר אחר לטפל באנשים אחרים ואז לעבוד ככה.
כן. אתה רואה, וזה לא קשור ללוגיסטיקה של דבר מלבד חיפזון.
כאילו, כי מה שקורה כאן זה שבעצם ה משפיע פעמיים.
כאילו תחשוב על זה ככה. אם לא היה לך את זה כאן לא היה כתוב כפול.
זה היה כתוב c כפול D כן היסודי הוא מגיע לך.
בסדר מה זה חשוב? אז עכשיו לשנות קצת?
אז עכשיו לשנות קצת את A? כן היית רוצה לראות כמה כמה לשנות קצת את ה משפיע על התורשה, אינו מושפע איך שהוא השפיע על זה וזה ישפיע על זה.
אני רק בפגישת כאן שרשרת. אני יודע שאני צריך להכפיל אותו ואני מקבל את ההשפעה שלי.
כן, וזה לא מעניין אותי. כן, זה פשוט קבוע, זה פוסל את זה.
זה לא מקרה קשה, אבל. אבל במקרה כאן אתה אומר A משפיע עליי פעמיים.
יכול להיות שעזבתי את זה כדי להקטין.
הזזתי פה איזה כיוון כדי להקטין את זה, אבל בכלל לא לקחתי בחשבון את זה שבעצם גם בתוך סיפור שכתוב האי קפריסין, אז כאילו בכלל לא כאן זה.
זה הולך להשתנות בעקבות זאת אומרת משפיע עליך פעמיים בדיוק אתה מתנהג כמו שהיה עליך.
למה אתה זה? זה קרה בשרשרת. הרב בן אדם אומר את מה שהוא אומר זה זה נגיד שלך פונקציה דו מימדית במקרה הזה נכון קצת מוזר.
אז יש לך ילדים? או.
איך? בעזרת השפעה של לפיד, ליברמן ובנימין שאיפת הזוכים.
עכשיו אני יודע שהנשים של נשים יפות זה מרקיע שחקים.
ג'יפ של AMG סטייל של ביבי וחברים טובים לא משנה איזה.
במטה הכללי ג'י של HP ואיש אמיץ אחד של H2.
נכון, ואפילו לא במקרה הכללי.
אה, כן, כאן אני פשוט אחד מהם. וואו, אז הוא צפה לזה?
כן. אז בעצם הדבר הזה שווה משהו?
ל. כדי לעשות את זה. ביחד אני צריכה להסתכל.
אני צריכה להתייחס ספציפית. לרוב אני לא סתם אני מסתכלת.
42. משם כל.
מה שאני רואה זה איך אני יכול להבטיח שכל הזדמנות על אחד כזה תתקבל.
נכון, זה נכון שיש מימד אחד. שאתם רואים איקס תמורה ביחסים עם השני.
אתה יודע, זה פשוט מתבטל. כן בדיוק.
קודם כל, כל המסלולים האחרים כאן אתה כאילו גם סוחב עליהם, אבל בעצם נתפסים.
בדיוק. כן, נגזרת האחרונה שלהם היא אפס.
בדיוק. בשום שלב אתה. עכשיו אפשר הפעולה.
אני חושב שאפילו. שלנו.
אסכולת ירושלים. זכאי.
האם. אז כן.
אז אתה חוזר להיות. 12.
מאז. שס.
של. הגיע.
יש לי הצעה. 3.
ג'ניפר לופז. הנשיא פרס.
25. בסוף.
איך שזה. בסוף השנה הצבא נכנס.
אז. צריך.
אוקיי. אז.
הרבה שנים. או לכל הפחות כמה כמות מכובדת של שנים.
ארמנים בעצם נתקלו באיזושהי בעיה שדי חסמה את הפרטיות שלהם.
אני מבין שדנו בה כבר באי מייל ואני לא ארחיב.
אני רק אזכיר אותה. מה שנקרא בעיה של ונשים וספרדים כבדים.
בגדול. מה שמה שאפשר לומר לגבי הארמנים זה שהרבה פעמים מה שהיה קורה בפרקטיקה של השימוש שלהם זה שהגנבים היו או מאוד גדולים או מאוד קטנים.
בעצם החישוב של הגרדיאן טיים מה שהיה יוצר בעיות כי כן, כל מיני בעיות למשל של סבלתי נומרית.
כן, שאם נגיד אם יש לנו קליינטים עצומים אז זה אומר שממש איזשהו הבדל מאוד קטן.
כן, הבדל מאוד קטן. כן, בהגדרה של הפונקציה בערכים שאנחנו נותנים, הפונקציה יכול להוביל אותנו לשינויים מאוד גדולים בצד של כן בצד עדכון שאנחנו נעשה.
והצד ההפוך לזה זה שבעצם ה training data כבר הופך לקצת לא משנה נכון עם הגרדיאנט הוא מאוד מאוד קטן,
אז כבר אז מה שקורה זה שכן מאוד מאוד קשה לנו לשערך אותו בצורה אמינה.
זה מאוד קרוב לאפס ושוב אנחנו נתקלים ואנחנו נתקלים בבעיות בשימוש פרקטי שלהם.
גם אם באופן תיאורטי היה ניתן פשוט לעדכן את הגרדיאנט ככה ולהגיד אוקיי, אז לוס ממוזער על ידי עדכוני גרדיאנט מאוד גדולים.
מכיוון שאנחנו תמיד עובדים באיזה שהוא פרסי שם ספין נכון, הם מחזיקים כמות מסוימת של כן של דיוק אחרי האפס.
בסופו של דבר זה מאוד מקשה. מאוד מקשה לנהל את את בעיית האופטימיזציה בצורה מדוייקת.
אם אנחנו מתעסקים בבגדי אנטי מאוד קטנים, למה בעצם נוצרו הגרדיאנט עם המתפוצצים?
כן, מה שנקרא הגרדיאנט עם העצומים, הגנטיים הנעלמים.
כלומר אלה שהערכים שלהם מאוד קטנים בנורמה או מאוד גדולים.
אז לא נוכיח את זה. אבל מבחינת האינטואיציה, האינטואיציה אומרת סך הכל דבר.
הרעיון הוא רעיון מאוד פשוט. ציפרמיל הוא בעצם אומר פחות או יותר את הדבר הבא רשת נוירונים שהיא בעצם RNA.
אם כדי לחשב את הגרדיאנט של פונקציית פלוס כפונקציה של כן ערכים שהם בשלב כן במקום הרבה יותר נמוך אם תרצו בגרף החישוב.
כן, זאת אומרת דברים שהם יחסית רחוקים מבחינת המקומות.
בעצם, כדי לחשב את זה מה שקורה פה Gain שהוא בעצם כן יישום של כלל השרשרת.
מה שהוא אומר לנו זה שאנחנו צריכים לחשב גרדיאנט עם כל מיני גרדיאנט עם חלקים.
זאת אומרת, צריכה כל מיני נגזרות חלקיות נכון של בעצם זה יהיו המשקלים של הצלעות שאותם אנחנו מחשבים לאורך הדרך בגרף החישוב והמשקל של המסלול הכולל.
כן שהמסלול הכולל של העדכון יהיה בעצם מכפלה של המשקלים האלה.
עכשיו, אם גרף החישוב שלנו מאוד עמוק נכון, כאן הוא סך הכל היה רק בעומק שלוש, אבל ככלל,
טקסטים שאנחנו עובדים בהם, אפילו אחרי שאנחנו מחלקים אותם בסגמנטים וכן הלאה, ודאי הרבה יותר משלוש.
כן? אז בעצם כדי לעשות כדי לבצע גרדיאנט ביחס לפרמטרים כן, או ביחס לחישובים שנמצאים עמוק בתוך גרף החישוב, אנחנו צריכים להכפיל הרבה משקולות אחת בשנייה,
נכון או הרבה נגזרות חלקיות אחת בשנייה, אם הנגזרות, אם הם ככלל בערכים קטנים אחד וככל הנראה אנחנו די מהר נגיע לאפס.
כן, לפחות אם הם חסומים חסומים. מה שנקרא כן, אם הם חסומים באחד מהצד השני, כלומר גדולים מ 1 אז הם יתפוצצו.
כן ובגדול. סוג תופעות מהסוג הזה.
כן, כמובן זה שוב זה לא הוכחה פורמלית בכלל, כי המשקלים האלה הם לא קבועים.
זה לא באמת סדרה הנדסית, אבל האינטואיציה הזאת בעצם מתממשת.
יש לנו מסלולים ארוכים בבק פרופ גייט. כן, בדיוק מהסיבה שציינו קודם כי בעצם עומק גרף החישוב הוא מאוד.
גדול והמסלולים הארוכים האלה, המשקל שלהם מתקבל כמכפלה של צלעות,
ומה שאנחנו מקבלים זה או עלייה אקספוננציאלית או ירידה אקספוננציאלית במשקל של המסלול, מה שגורם לגרדיאן כי מאוד קטנים או מאוד גדולים.
וזאת הייתה בעיה במשך הרבה שנים, דבר שכן, דבר שבעצם גרם לו יישומיות מוגבלת של הארמנים.
כן של הארמנים.
ובאופן פרקטי, למשל מודלי שפה, מה שהיינו רואים כאילו הדרך איכשהו להתגבר על זה ולנהל את הדברים בצורה סבירה הייתה לקטום בעצם את העומק של הגרף,
או במילים אחרות להפסיק את הבטן, לזרוק מסלולים שהם יותר ארוכים מאז מאיזשהו עומק מסוים.
אבל זה בדיוק מחזיר אותנו למצב שהוא דומה לשרשראות מרקוב.
נכון שהתעסקנו אותם, כי אם אנחנו לא מגלגלים את הגרדיאנט יותר מ שלוש ארבע צעדים אחורה, אז בעצם יהיה לנו בעייתי לתפוס תלויות שהם תלויות יותר רחוקות.
כן, כי הדרך היחידה שלנו לתפוס אותם זה באיזושהי דרך מאוד עקיפה.
דרך כן, כי כי בעצם מה שהיה מאוד אחורה ישפיע על המצב, אולי בקרב בשלב קצת קדימה, אבל ההשפעה.
אבל אנחנו לא באמת לוקחים את זה בחשבון בטריינינג.
זאת אומרת, גם אם הוא עקרונית RNA הופך להיות פונקציה של משהו של תוכן שקרה 10 או 20 צעדים אחורה בגלל שה עדכוני גרדיאנט שלנו לא מתחשבים בזה.
אנחנו בפקטור לא מנצלים את הסיגנל שאנחנו יכולים לקבל בצורה אופטימלית או אפילו קרוב לזה.
הדבר הזה עבר בעצם מהפכה כתוצאה מעבודה מאוד משפיעה שנקראת LST.
אם כן, שזה קיצור של Long.
שורת memory כן הוכרה היטב רשמית, אומר מ 1997 שבגדול הראה איזושהי דרך להתגבר על הבעיה הזאת של אקספלורר, דינג ו Machine Riders.
אני לא יודע אם הם לומדים, אני חושב שבאמת מזכירים את זה, אבל לא לומדים את זה מאוד לעומק מכיוון שהטכנולוגיה הזאת היא קיימת.
סופר סיד כן על ידי הטרנספורמר. אם אז אני גם לא אכנס איתה לעומק.
אני רק אומר שהבעיה הזאת היא בעיה שיש לה שיש לה פתרונות אפקטיביים.
למעשה, הפתרונות האלה הם מאוד אפקטיביים, כפי שהראו כפי שהראתה העבודה מ 2016.
בעוד אפקטיביים בהקשר של מודלי שפה, אני מתכוון לומר כן, כפי שהראה 2016 ב 2016 תהליך זה ואחרים כן,
מעין הוא היו אז בגדול הוא בדק את השאלה הבאה עכשיו אנחנו חוזרים שוב למודל A שפה ARM,
אם כן, או מבוססי מבוססי ARM, והוא חזר לבעיה שכבר נתקלנו בה,
שהיא בעיית ההתאמה במספר של הפועל הראשי במשפט עם מה שנקרא גרעין של הנושא עם המספר של הנושא נכון ודיברנו על בדיוק מקרים כאלה.
The Rocks in the back בית אדוארד, אבל The rose device by the door is.
נכון ודרוזים Device זה Charles red.
אותו דבר נכון. כל הדברים האלה, ואני יכול גם להמשיך ולהעריך את זה עוד ועוד ועוד ובגדול.
מה שאני צריך זה לתפוס את את הדיפנדר הנסי הזה.
כן, בין המילה שמופיעה כאן לבין המילה את הגרעין שעשויה להופיע לא מעט מילים אחורה.
אפשר להכניס פה עוד ועוד דברים באמצע, כשהוא בעצם מסתכל על עד כמה טוב זה נלמד על ידי הרנין Language Models כפונקציה של שני מימדים עיקריים.
אוקיי, האחד מהם זה המרחק. אוקיי, כמה תקנים יש באמצע?
שזה בעצם בדיוק הדבר ששרשרת מרקוב אמרנו תתקשה בו נכון?
כי עם שרשרת מרקוב ממימד כזה שלא מכיל את Roses, אז מה לעשות, לא נצליח לחזות את זה בצורה טובה, כי כל שאר המילים באמצע יהיו אותו דבר.
אז זה דבר אחד. והדבר השני זה structure. כן, כלומר הדברים שנמצאים באמצע שאולי עשויים להטות אותו.
אז מה הרעיון כאן? הרעיון הוא בעצם תראו אם מה שאם אני עכשיו מסתכל על The process in the case בידי הרי.
לעומת Terrorists in the face. בתור R.
אוקיי. בשני המקרים האלה r ו roses הם, אני חושב, רחוקים באותה מידה.
נכון, יש שש מילים ביניהם, אבל יש הבדל בין פוטנציאלים בין הדברים האלה שהוא מה.
מה זה בדיוק דור והכרס? כי מה זה יכול להיות?
הרי גם ככה בדיוק יכול להיות. זה מה שנקרא יתפוס ויתפוס דבר ביזנס נכון?
הוא ראה צ'ארלס. אז הוא אמר נכון, אבל הדבר הזה הוא דיסלקט ואני אראה את זה מיד ברגע שאני אסתכל על הקינדר פארט שלו.
נכון שהוא? גם Rose in the Face.
בית את This. אם הוא טעה בגלל זה אז הוא יגיד לי אם הוא צדק בגלל זה סליחה אז עכשיו הוא טעה נכון?
כי שיניתי את המעוז, לא שיניתי את הג'וב, אז עכשיו הוא טעה אם?
כן, אם הוא לא צעיר, אם הוא צדק, אם הוא סליחה, אם הוא באמת לקח בחשבון את את Roses ולא את Rose, אז כנראה שהוא ימשיך לצעוק גם אחרי שאני אשנה פה את Works.
אוקיי, אז בעצם הוא רצה לקחת בחשבון גם את איזה סוג the structure?
אז יש גב? כמעט אספקט, אז יש באמצע, כי אולי גם וייס נכון, גם זה Num.
אולי הוא יכול להתבלבל איתו, אבל גם זה לא היה נכון. נכון?
אני יכול להחליף אותו לאינדי ואז ICS?
או משהו בסגנון? יפה ומה שהוא מצא זה בעצם שסך הכל האלסטי המים הם ממש ממש טובים.
כן, הארמנים עם הסיפור הזה של להתמודד עם הבן מישהי והאקס Losing Random.
בגדול הוא מצא תוצאות מאוד מעודדות. הוא הסתכל על העבר.
רייט כן, על פשוט אחד בנושא כי הוא עשה כמה טעויות.
איזה אחוז טעויות הם עושים בין לחזות את הפועל נכון עם קונטרול לכל הדברים האלה.
כן, להשוות כל פעם דוגמה ברבים ויחיד ולשנות בצורה סיסטמטית ובגדול.
מה שהוא מראה זה שכשאין אין תביני Not.
אוקיי כאן תביני nurse כלומר אין באמצע destruction scale מסיחים מהסוג הזה.
בגדול אנחנו רואים שהאירו רייט כן עולה. זאת אומרת יש כאן מגמת עלייה.
לא רואים אותם. יש כאן מגמת עלייה, אם נתונה כן, אם היא מתונה, כלומר יש לה RNA אין.
למרות שהבעיה הזאת היא במידה רבה לא יודע אם נפתרה, אבל או זה Dress כן עלתה על ידי LST.
אם יש עדיין משמעות למרחק. אוקיי, זה כן.
הפרפורמנס יורד כפונקציה של כפונקציה המרחק, לפחות עבור הבעיה הזאת, אבל הוא יורד מאוד במתינות.
אוקיי, יורד מאוד במתינות.
הוא גם מסתכל על מה קורה. לגבי Structure כן, מה קורה כשמכניסים שם באמצע?
אז כאן הוא ראה שעד עשרה כתוב כן עשויים לשנות.
אוקיי, אז זה structure. כן עשויים לשנות. זאת אומרת ההכללה שהוא למד מצד אחד אוקיי, הגרף השמאלי בעצם מה שהוא אומר זה שהמורה היא כן run.
הפונקציה הרי קורנט. את הפרמטרים שהאימון יתכנס עליהם הם כאלה שיכולים לזכור שזה היה rose ולא Ross או ההפך, גם אם זה הופיע 14 מילים אחורה וגם יותר.
כן, זה סך הכל עולה בצורה מאוד מתונה. לא סופגים הרבה שגיאה, אבל בתנאי שלא תתבלבלו אותה יותר מדי.
כן, אל תכניסו שם יותר מדי באמצע מסיחים כל מיני דברים שהם עשויים להיתפס להם.
מה זה בעצם אומר? איך הוא פירש את הדבר הזה?
אז סליחה, אני אסיים את הזה. אבל אם מסתכלים על מצב שכן יש את teachers כמו סלקטור אז לא משנה.
אז מה שאנחנו רואים זה שכן יש הידרדרות. היא עדיין מתונה.
כן, היא עדיין מתונה והוא ישווה אותה לקו הירוק.
כאן זה בעצם קו ירוק שהוא מסתכל רק על הזהות של הנאנסות שהגיעו לפני ומנסה לחזות על פיה.
זאת אומרת, זה קלאסי Pierre שמה שאומרים לו זה אני עכשיו מסתכל על המשפט שבו מופיעים הדם צבעים Roses והסגול.
זהו, זה מה שאני אומר לכם לא אומר לכם איזה מילות מה לא בסדר.
אבל בלי זה אם בי טה טה טה טה טה.
עכשיו אני אומר לך מה המילה הבאה? כאילו, האם זה ISO?
אז כאן ההחלטה שלך היא בעצם על מה אתה יכול להסתמך כדי לחפות על?
אז אולי על הנאום האחרון? אולי אתה איכשהו חושב שהכלל ספר הזה למד שכן יש?
לא יודע באיזה שהיא צורה. אולי הוא לא השתמש בזה כי הוא אמר אולי זה לא נכון שהוא מסתמך רק על האחרון,
כי יכול להיות שהוא שם לב שהשתמשתי במילים מקשקש עכשיו מילים שאני לוקח בתור הגרעין של המשפט.
מילים קצת שונות מאשר המילים שאני משתמש בהם דרך model first אז אולי יש שם.
בקיצור, הוא ניסה לשלוט בעטיפה כדי כן לראות שזה לא טוב.
זה באמת תוצאה של הבנה תחבירית והוא באמת ראה שהוא אכן לומד משהו.
לגבי התחביר. נכון, עם סך הכל מה שהוא היה רגיש אליו עם כל מה שהוא היה עושה זה מוצא parts of speech בעצם ומסתכל על איזה Note ומסתכל על הנאום האחרון.
אז בעצם היינו עדיין מקבלים גרף כזה.
אולי נכון כי פה אין האוס באמצע, אין שום דבר שבלבל אותו אז הוא מסתכל על הנאום האחרון.
אין בעיה. ענן האחרון מופיע לפני 30 טוקינג על הכיפאק.
כל טוב, אני זוכר שזה סינגולר. הנה עדיין אני עולה מאוד לאט מבחינת הדיסטנס והכל טוב.
כן, אפילו שאני התעלמתי לגמרי מן התחביר, מלבד מימד אחד של התחביר שזה לזהות נאו.
זהו זה אומר לא, הוא עושה משהו יותר טוב.
נכון, הוא עושה משהו יותר טוב. הנה, אם אני סומך רק על הנאום אז אתם רואים שהוא הספר הזה כושל בצורה דרמטית.
זה הקו הירוק, אבל הם אינם ברב דסקטופ.
זה עולה בצורה הרבה יותר מתונה, אבל עדיין מה שהגרף הזה מראה זה שכן אפשר לבלבל אותו.
זאת אומרת, הוא למד תחביר, למד משהו עם לא רק מה זה Now עשה שם משהו חשוב, אבל.
לא יודע. שלושת רבעי כוח. כן. נגיד. בסדר.
יש לו עוד מה? יש לו עוד מה לעשות? אבל סך הכל אני חושב שלפחות באותו זמן, 2016 לפני עשור.
עכשיו תוצאות מאוד מעודדות, מאוד מרשימות, בוודאי ביחס ומרחב מודלס.
נכון שהיו טועים בעצם ברמה של chance level.
ברגע שהייתם מגדילים את הדיסטנס מעל למספר מילים שהם לוקחים בחשבון.
שאלות כן, זה מבקש 20 אחוז שנייה זה עדיין.
טוב, אני לא יודע מה אתה קורה טוב או לא טוב, אבל סך הכל תשים לב שזה בסטייג די חריג ביחס למה שבדרך כלל קורה.
נכון, בוא נחשוב אז זה מקרים שבהם יש לך בעצם.
נושא אנחנו בדיוק עכשיו נעבור לדבר על תחביר, אז נדבר על זה יותר לעומק.
אתה בעצם יש לכם נושא של המשפט, שאחריו מופיעים ארבעה נאומים שהם כולם לא הנושא של המשפט.
הם כאילו הם דברים אחרים שבמקרה נמצאים שם ואז מופיע הפועל.
זה כאילו זה ממש אני בטוח שתמצא משפטים כאלה באנגלית.
נראה לי שלא. המון כאילו נכון, אתה בדרך כלל אומר אולי כן דחה את זה?
לא יודע. תכלס נקסט. בום.
בסדר, זה יכול להיות. אולי אתה רוצה להגיד כן.
Soccer גיים דת will be here next.
אין, לא יודע מה דסטיני דיון עשיתי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
בסדר, אבל אם אתה צריך לחכות מלא מלא מילים ועוד כל מיני נאומים עד שאתה עובר את התקופה של המשפט.
זה כנראה משפט שלא בנוי בצורה הכי זורמת, נכון?
אז זה אומר אוקיי, עליהם אתה מגיע ל 20 אחוז דיוק צריך לומר לו וואלה, בסדר.
ביחס למצב קודם לגמרי לגמרי בתחום, הסביר.
אוקיי, לא, לא פוסל. על כן לא, לא.
המילה האחרונה, כאמור, זה המצב ביחס לפני עשר שנים. בסדר.
טוב, נעבור ל. בפרק הבא.
שבה אנחנו נדבר קצת על דקדוק.
אנחנו נדבר קצת על דקדוק. אנחנו בעצם החלק הזה לא יהיה חלק חישובי בפרק הזה.
זה איזשהו פרק קצר שאנחנו נרצה לתת איזשהו הקדמה, מתוך הנחה שחלקכם ודאי מכירים היטב את התחום, אבל אחרים בטח לא התעסקו בדקדוק מאז בבית הספר התיכון.
אז אולי כדאי לחזור על כמה מושגים בסיסים כי הם ישמשו אותנו בהמשך.
בסדר, אז דבר ראשון מה זה דקדוק? כן או גרנדה אנגלית?
אז מסתבר שהשאלה הזאת, שאולי נשמעת כמו שאלה כזאת קצת יבשה,
היא שאלה שעוררה מחלוקות אדירות וגרמה לכן גרמה פיצולים רפואי רוויי אמוציות לאורך המחצית השנייה של המאה ה 20,
ובעצם יש כל מיני גישות שונות לגבי לשאלה הזאת.
אז בעצם הגישה הקלאסית אני חושב זאת שאנחנו עוד מוצאים בספרי דקדוק של לטינית ושל יוונית עתיקה ושל סנסקריט.
בעצם חושבים על זה פשוט. מה זה דקדוק של שפה? זה אוסף החוקים והעקרונות.
כן, החוקיות שבעצם בעזרתה אנחנו מייצרים משפטים בשפה.
נכון, יש שפות שבהם התואר מגיע אחרי השם שאליו הוא מתייחס כמו.
עברית. נכון, כלב גדול ויש שפות שבהם הוא מגיע לפני.
כמו למשל אנגלית, נכון? דיג דוג או ברוסית?
אתה אומר זה גם. בצורה דומה.
נכון? נכון, ויש אבל כל מיני הבדלים אחרים.
נכון, כל מיני הבדלים אחרים הם רוסית. לא משנה.
יש כל מיני הבדלים בחוקים.
כשאנחנו לומדים שפה, בין אם אנחנו מחשב או בן אדם שלומד שפה ראשונה, שנייה שלישית, אנחנו צריכים ללמוד את החוקים האלה מעבר ללקסיקון כדי לדעת להשתמש בשפה.
אבל אוקיי, הגדרה יותר אבסטרקטית שבעצם הומצאה זה כן בגדול על ידי הזרם, מה שנקרא גם נרטיבי בבלשנות זה בעצם לחשוב על.
על הדקדוק כאיזה שהיא כן בעצם כאיזושהי רגולריות שיש בה מיפוי בין.
צורה לבין תוכן. אוקיי, אז מה הרעיון כאן בעצם?
אתם יכולים לחשוב עכשיו על שפה? בתור איזשהו כלי שמביע משמעות?
בסדר, לכלי הזה יש צורה מסוימת. נגיד אם אם זה שפה כתובה אז טקסט, ואם זה שפה דבורה אז כן, צלילים הגאים וכן הלאה.
אם זה שפת סימנים מה זה תנועות? אז לא משנה.
יש, אבל איזה שהיא צורה, משהו שאפשר לתפוס באמצעים החושים שלנו ויש את המשמעות, את התוכן שלה.
ובין שני הקטבים האלה יש איזושהי חוקיות במיפוי ביניהם.
כן, זה לא שהכל הולך. אומנם החוקיות הזאת היא לא חוקיות מושלמת, כי למשל אם אתם אם אני עכשיו אתן לכם איזושהי שפה שאתם לא מכירים כנראה.
ואני אגיד לכם את המילים לא יודע מה כלב, חתול ופרה לא בטוח שתצליחו יותר מדי לנחש איזה מהם אומר נכון.
אתם יכולים לנסות את זה בסוגריים.
כנראה שבהרבה מקרים יותר מתאמץ לבל כן, אבל לא הרבה יותר מדי לבן, אז זה גם דבר מעניין.
אבל במקרים מסוימים אז אין, אין יותר מדי חוקיות.
אבל במקרים אחרים בוודאי יש. נכון, סדר המילים ברוב השפות הוא פחות או יותר קבוע.
אמרנו כלב גדול יעבוד בעברית גדול, כלב לא כל כך ובאנגלית ההפך.
וכן הלאה. את החוקיות הזאת רגולריות הזאת אנחנו קוראים דקדוק.
גישה שלישית, מה שנקראת פייסט. כן, בלשנות מבוססת שימוש אומרת אנחנו עכשיו חושבים על זה.
בעצם בעצם מה זה שפה? שפה זה איזשהו קישור?
כן, זה איזשהו Skills שאנחנו לומדים. כן, לא בדיוק חשוב איך אנחנו לומדים את זה.
אבל, אבל הנקודה היא שאנחנו לומדים את זה מאיזשהו ניסיון מצטבר, ראיות שמגיעים מגיעות אלינו, ניסיון שלנו בשימוש בשפה,
בין אם כן דוברים או כששומעים אוקיי והצורה הזאת היא אנחנו מארגנים את זה באיזושהי צורה שמאפשרת לנו הכללה.
נכון? כי ברור אנחנו לא יודעים רק להבין את אותם דברים ששמענו מילה במילה בעבר יש לנו כנראה את השיעור הזה, למשל בעבר אני מניח.
אלא אם אולי הייתם שנה שעברה לא שמעתם, ואני מקווה שבכל זאת הצלחתם לעקוב אחריו, נכון?
אז סך הכל יש לנו יכולת הכללה, זה די ברור.
ובעצם אם שמים את הפוקוס שם אז זה טיפה הקדמה תיאורטית, אבל לצרכינו בקורס במדעי הקוגניציה אני כמובן מלמד את זה אחרת,
אבל לצרכינו כאן, בחוג למדעי המחשב, אנחנו שואלים את נקודת המבט כן התועלתנית למה אנחנו צריכים כאן מערך, כלומר מה אנחנו נעשה איתו?
אז מה נעשה עם גרף? מסתבר שאפשר לעשות איתו כל מיני דברים, והנה אני חושב בכותרות אלה שני הדברים העיקריים שאפשר לעשות איתו.
דבר ראשון שאפשר לעשות איתו זה לפרק יחידות שפתיות מורכבות כמו משפטים, טקסטים.
בדרך כלל יהיה משפטים בהקשר של דקדוק או חתיכות ממשפטים, רכיבים ליחידות יותר פשוטות בצורה שיכולה לסייע לנו בלמידה.
ובהחלט, אוקיי, אז למשל, אם אני עכשיו מפרק את הכל, את המילה כלב גדול ושועל חום, ואני לא יודע בכיתה כיתה לבנה,
בעצם אני אומר כולם הם מתפרקים למשהו שהוא מקטגוריית תואר ומשהו בקטגוריה שם שהם מופיעים אחד עם השני ואז התואר מתייחס לשם.
אז הדבר הזה מאפשר לי הכללה יותר טובה, נכון? כי עכשיו אני יכול להפעיל את אותו חוק גם לגבי מילים אחרות שהם תארים.
במילים אחרות שהם שמות עצם. אוקיי, אז זה Structure.
בסיס השני זה סמנטיקה Information. כן, כי בעצם הרבה פעמים הדקדוק גם יש בו בעצם תוכן.
מבחינה סמנטית כן, זה שמשהו הוא תואר אז תואר הוא הרבה פעמים מביע תכונה למשל כן, אז אמן.
אם יש אם אני יודע. כיתה גדולה זה שם ואחרי זה תואר.
אז אני יכול לדעת שככל הנראה, גם אם לא בטוח, מדובר כאן על סוג של ישות, סוג של אובייקט.
במקרה הזה כיתה כן וסוג של תכונה שלה, שבמקרה הזה גדולה ואנחנו נראה דוגמאות לשני הדברים האלה.
ועוד דבר שחשוב להגיד לפני שככה צוללים האינדיקטור זה שכשאנחנו מתעסקים בשפה אנחנו בגדול לא יכולים להסתפק במבנה ליניארי.
כן, כי אתם יכולים להגיד לי במידה רבה של צדק, אבל ברור שיש מבנה בשפה.
כן, הרי דיברנו על מבנה כבר. גם בדיונים שלנו עד כה דיברנו על זה שהמילים הם לא בלתי תלויות אחת בשנייה מופיעות בסדר מסוים, נכון?
וראינו, אפילו אם RNA יכול ללמוד, לא יכול ללמוד מה קורה עם זה וכן הלאה.
ומרקוס צ'יינז. אז כן, אז דיברנו על איך מבצעים אופטימיזציה גלובלית.
אבל בעצם אחת התובנות הבסיסיות לגבי שפה זה שבגדול אנחנו צריכים כנראה משהו שהוא מעבר לסדר לינארי.
זאת אומרת, חלק מהמבנה הוא בעצם מבנה היררכי.
כן, לא. לא מבנה של דברים שמופיעים רק משמאל או מימין אחד ושני.
אלה גם דברים שנמצאים באיזשהו מובן מעל או מתחת אחד לשני, גם אם לא רואים אותו בצורה כל כך מיידית.
והנה ניקח דוגמה פשוטה שני משפטים שמבחינת מחרוזות, גם בעברית, אגב, זה עובד באותה צורה.
מבחינת מחרוזות הם דומים מאוד אחד לשני.
ההבדל הוא במילת אחת בעברית זה אפילו יהיה באות אחת.
נכון, משהו כמו המחבלים לקחו את הקופסאות.
מה שזה לא יהיה שהם מצאו להאנגר ושהם מצאו בה גם כן.
בדיוק אז זה מין אות אחת שמשתנה. הסריגים מאוד דומים, אבל ההבדל כאן, כפי שאני מניח שאתם חשים, הוא קצת יותר גדול ממילה אחת לעומת מילה אחרת.
בעצם, מה קורה כאן? מה ההבדל המהותי בין המשפטים יש משמעות וספציפית.
בעצם בשאלה למה המילה הזאת בכלל מתייחסת למילה שמסומנת באדום, נכון?
האם היא מתייחסת לדבר שמצוי איפשהו? או שהיא מתייחסת למשהו שלקחו לאנשים?
נכון? זאת אומרת, השינוי במלית הזאת בעצם משנה מה שאנחנו עוד מעט נקרא לו את מבנה הכמויות של המשפט.
אוקיי. ואנחנו נגדיר את זה בצורה קצת יותר מדויקת.
כן? כל התקופה שאתה דיברת על המבנה סביבה בניין.
צריך כאילו ברור לי מה זה אומר, אבל.
מסתדר עם מה שכתבת? כאילו איך אני רואה פה שזה ליניארי?
כן. אז לא, לא הגדרתי את זה בצורה מדויקת.
ולמעשה בלי זה אתה יודע, קורס הרבה יותר אינטנסיבי בבלשנות.
יהיה לי קשה להגדיר את זה בצורה לגמרי מדויקת, אבל ניסיתי יותר לפנות לאינטואיציה שלכם.
אוקיי, ובעצם לשאול את הדבר הבא כן, בעצם לשאול.
אתה יודע מה? אולי נציב את זה מול משהו אחר כדי שזה יהיה ברור?
בוא נגיד שהיית לוקח את המשפט Can לתרץ טוק the day.
That found. Behind the hunger.
אוקיי, הייתי מחליף את האין פה, למי היית בסדר?
אז יש לי עכשיו שלושה משפטים נכון לאותו משפט, פעם אחת עם טוב, פעם אחת עם In, פעם אחת עם BI.
בסדר. האם שניים מהמשפטים האלה באיזשהו מובן נראים לך יותר דומים אחד לשני מבחינת המבנה שלהם מהאין?
ואין למה? כי בעצם המקום של זה ביחס זה כאילו זה מה שאמרתי שבעצם הוא לקח.
כן, בדיוק. זאת אומרת, הם התייחסו כי בעצם הטור הזה הוא מתייחס, הוא בעצם אפשר לחשוב על כעונה.
על השאלה לאן לקחו, בעוד שאין עונה על השאלה איפה מצאו?
וגם אבי עונה על השאלה איפה מצאו כן.
אז בעצם מה שקורה כאן זה שלמרות שעל string ים האלה הם זהים מלבד המילה הזאת?
כן, בחלק מהמקרים השינוי הזה במילה גורם לך להגיד שהדבר שביחס אליו המתפרשים הוא נמצא.
מה זה? חמש מילים אחורה ובשני הוא נמצא מילה אחת אחורה.
אוקיי, וזה בדיוק מה שאני מתכוון שאני מתכוון להיררכיה.
כלומר, אני מתכוון לומר שיש כאן איזשהם פניות שהם מעבר לטעויות הלינארית.
מה מופיע מיד לפני, מה מופיע מיד אחרי? או שתיים לפני או שתיים אחרי זה כאילו זה קשור לאיך המשפט הזה בנוי.
הדבר הקצת קונטרה אינטואיטיבי פה הוא שאין לנו גישה ישירה למבנה הזה, ולמעשה אפשר מאוד להתווכח מה זה בדיוק המבנה הזה.
בגלל זה אני כרגע עוד לא מדבר במושגים האלה. כן, אני בדרך כלל מדבר במושגים של יש כאן איזשהי תופעה שהיינו אידיאלית, רוצים לתפוס, לייצג?
אוקיי, עוד שאלות. כן.
טוב וצריך. כן, וזה איזשהי הערת אגב שהיינו שמחים.
אחד הסיבות שבעצם שהוא גם בהקשר הקודם שמסייע לנו בהכללה, אנחנו עדיין זוכרים מדבק, אבל מינץ כן.
יש. אחות את הכיתה.
יש לכם עכשיו אוכל? משהו כזה פה?
לא רק אצלי. שעה שלושים. עוד עשר דקות, עוד עשר דקות ועוד לפי הסדר.
כן. אז איפה היד? אז בקיצור, מה שאנחנו זוכרים כל הזמן נדבק.
אבל מה שבעצם תופעות בשפה.
למרות שיש לנו אפילו בעידן האינטרנט והכל כן זה קורפוסים אדירים במדיהם.
אנחנו זוכרים שתופעות בשפה יש פעילות סביב שהם.
אם אתם זוכרים את זה מהשיעור הראשון, כלומר אנחנו, אנחנו כל הזמן נמשיך ונתקל בתופעות נדירות, גם אם לא.
תופעות שאולי אין לנו עליהן מספיק סטטיסטיקה, וגם אם אספנו על מספיק סטטיסטיקה על מילים,
אולי לא אספנו מספיק סטטיסטיקה על שרשראות מילים, בוודאי לא על משפטים ועל גופים יותר גדולים.
לכן בהחלט שימוש במבנה כדי לשפר את ההכללה הוא מבורך.
בסדר, זה בגדול לספרות. יפה אז הדבר המושג הראשון שאני רוצה שאנחנו נדון בו זה מושג שנקרא מילה שעד כה השתמשנו בו כל הזמן למעשה במהלך הקורס,
אבל לא טרחנו להגיד עליו יותר מדי, כי פשוט הנחנו שאנחנו יודעים מה זה מילים.
נכון, אנחנו יודעים מה זה מילים. סך הכל זה לא איזה מושג. כן, יותר מדי אזוטרי.
אבל מסתבר שלנסות להגדיר מה זה מילה זה צרה די רצינית.
כן, צרה די רצינית, שלמעשה היא עדיין תחום מחקר פעיל.
כן, של מה זה מילה, עדיין לא נושא שהוא בדיוק מוסכם, ויש כאן כל מיני גישות.
הגישה הפרקטית שהרבה פעמים או אני חושב מה שנקטנו עד כה בקורס זה פשוט להסתכל על דברים שמופיעים בין שני רווחים ולהגיד זאת מילה.
כן, שזה גישה לשפות שאין בהם מה שנקרא יותר מדי מורפולוגיה.
אנחנו עוד נדבר מה זה מורפולוגיה. כלומר אין להם יותר מדי מבנה פנימי למילים כמו הטיות שיש לנו לדוגמה בעברית או דברים כאלה.
זאת גישה שאולי פחות או יותר סבירה. אבל לא כל השפות הם כאלה ואפילו השפות שהם כן כאלה.
מה לגבי שפת דבורה עכשיו? אין לנו אינדיקציות.
זה לא שאנחנו אומרים לא יודע אם הסתכלתם פעם על קבצי WAV.
נגיד או משהו כזה. כן, על כאילו הסיגנל האקוסטי של דיבור כן.
אז אם יצא לכם להסתכל אתם בוודאי ראיתם שזה לא נראה כמו מילה שקט, מילה שקט, מילה שקט.
זה ממש לא נראה ככה. המילים הם קצת עולות אחת על השניה ולפעמים באמצע מילה יש קצת רווח.
יש לו אולי אפילו יותר גדול מאשר בין המילים. בקיצור לא שיטה טובה בשפה דבורה.
מה לגבי מילים שיש ביניהם רווח ואז הרווח הזה הפך למקס כמו Kickstarter?
כן, נתתי פה כל מיני דוגמאות. אומנם זה קצת משנה.
אני חושב שהיה פשוט איזושהי שהיא תנועה בזמן ביניהם.
כן, שקיק סטארט התחיל בתור שתי מילים. או שאולי בהקשרים מסוימים זה שתי מילים בהקשרים אחרים זה עם מקף ואחרים זה בלי בכלל סתם.
אז מה קרה? מה קרה שם? זה הפך מכמה מילים למילה אחת.
מה לגבי שפות שאין בהן רווחים? כן, יש שפות כאלה שבכלל אין רווחים כמו נגיד למשל סינית.
כן, מנדרין צ'יינז, סינית מנדרינית שבכלל כותבים בלי רווחים.
וצריך בעצמכם להבין לפי ההקשר איפה נגמרת ומתחילה מילה או שפות כמו עברית, אפילו שבהם בין חלק מהמילים יש רווחים, אבל לא בין כולם.
נכון, כמו נגיד מילות יחס בא לכם?
נכון שאתם נצמדות מה שנקרא כלי טקסט וכל מיני דברים כאלה.
אז אולי זה לא השיטה היא בוא נאמר קירוב בסדר, אפס בסדר, אבל לא נראה כמו משהו בספק.
אז היו כל מיני הבלשנים לאורך השנים שנדרשו לשאלה הזאת.
הנה ציטוט מעדות ספיר, הסוציולוג והבלשן הנודע וואנג שמאלה Completely set sing bit of Islam.
תדמייני in the width בסאנדנס Resources. אז זה באמת ניסוח מאוד יפה.
לא בדיוק ברור איך מממשים בעזרת זה. טוב, כנראה זה נכון.
כאילו איך? אוקיי, יש לי טקסט. מה עכשיו אני עושה את זה?
מה זה אומר? שזה קונפליקט? ליסה בספינינג אנחנו מבינים שמדובר על משהו שלא לטעמו נושא משמעות בפני עצמו.
אבל והוא קטן או מינימלי אז לא בדיוק ברור.
כן, וגם באמת הציטוט השני כאן זה זרמון Sci the World is the most Conflict, יוני טבלה, שוויץ אינדיפנדנט, The meaning form.
כן, ואני חושב שההגדרה בכיוונים האלה.
אולי המצוטטת ביותר היא זאת של בלומפילד לאום בלומפילד.
Word עפי form הוא הצד הזנת כאן אינטגרלי או טור או לספרי Forms words מינימום.
ככה הוא קרא לזה. אבל גם זה מעלה שאלות.
כי מה זה בדיוק פריפול? נכון, יש מילים שלא יכולות להופיע בפני עצמה.
נגיד כמו זה נכון, זה בגדול דורש אחריו שיגיע משהו.
כן, אז האם הוא חופשי או לא חופשי?
מה לגבי כן? מה לגבי דברים שהם?
כן. מה לגבי באמת? כאילו איפה בדיוק ההגדרה?
איפה עובר קו הגבול בין משהו שניתן לפצל או שלא ניתן לפצל?
ובאמת, הגישה העכשווית הגישה העכשווית בגדול מבדילה בין שני סוגים של מילים וזה חשוב.
אני חושב כן להכיר את המושגים האלה, גם אם תחום העיסוק העיקרי שלכם הוא לא עוסק בנטייה של מילים.
כן חשוב להגדיר ולהכיר בעצם גישה אחת היא או סליחה שני.
ניסח את זה מחדש. לפי הגישה הזאת ניתן לחשוב על מילים בשני מימדים שהם לא סותרים אחד את השני,
אלא פשוט לפי הגישה הזאת יש שני סוגים של מילים שהם עשויים להיות שונים אחד מהשני במשפט נתון.
האחד מהם זה מה שנקרא מילים לוגיות. כן, כלומר מילים שמוגדרים על בסיס קריטריונים צלילים כמו נגיד למשל מבנה הברות.
כן, איזה שפות יש מבנה? הברות מסוים? נכון? אני לא יודע אם אתם מכירים יפנית, נגיד אם אין שם הברות סגורות, נכון?
אז לא יודע אם מישהו מכם יצא לו לשמוע יפנית. כן, אז הכל מסתיים שם בתנועה.
כן. וואו, אז האו או אבל אין שם דברים כמו לא יודע.
את כן שזה נגמר בעיצור העבר.
אז דברים שקשורים לבינה, הדברות, דברים שקשורים לדה פרוזה, הודיה כן, כלומר הניגון של הדיבור רווחים.
כן, זה פאלס פנומנלי. זאת אומרת כל מיני הגדרות שמגדירות מילים פשוט ביחס לצורה.
כן לצורה פונולוגית. לאיזה לחן משמעות בתוך הסיגנל הצלילי.
גישה אחרת שעשויה להוביל לפרדיגמה אחרות, מסתכלת על מילים דקדוקיות,
כלומר מילים שיש להם איזושהי משמעות קונבנציונלית ושהם יכולים לעבור כל מיני הטיות או כל מיני תהליכים מורפולוגיים,
כמו למשל יחיד, יחיד רבים או כן או שפה של של ספק SAS או של פרי פיקס זו יש שפות שבהם יש מכפלות,
כלומר שנגיד מילה ביחיד זה נגיד לא יודע דבר ואז אותה מילה ביחיד זה נגיד בארבע כן וככה במקום להוסיף אם או אות
או אס בסוף אז יש כל מיני תהליכים מורפולוגיים ואפשר להגדיר מילה ביחס ליחידה שעוברת תהליכים מורפולוגיים.
כן, מהו האטום שעובר תהליכים מורפולוגיים ולקרוא לזה מילה, אבל זה יביא פרדי קצוות שעשויות להיות שונות אחת מהשנייה.
נכון, לדוגמא, יכול להיות נגיד למשל, הנה בירת מלזיה.
כן, מה היא בירת מלזיה? קואלה נכון?
כן. מי אמר אוקי, אבל ברור. נכון, המילים האלה הם כל אחת מהם פונולוגית, אומרים אותה ממש כמילה נפרדת.
באותה מידה שתגיד לא יודע מה באת בכדור.
נכון, אבל. אבל ברור שכל יחידה דקדוקית זה יחידה אחת.
אין לך מה לעשות עם אחד מהם. אין לזה ממש משמעות, כי את אחד מהם תמיד מופיעות ביחד.
כן, הזה ואפילו האמת, יש ביניהם רווח, כך שאפילו זה לא יעזור לך לחלק לפי רווחים.
כן, זה סתם דוגמה אחת. אז יש בעצם המון כאלה. אתם יכולים גם לחשוב בעצמכם על רבים.
ומה שחשוב לצרכינו זה שזה לא סתם קריטריון.
אל תחפשו את הסגמנטים הנכונה.
אתם כנראה לא תמצאו אותה. יש פה שני מימדים שכל אחד מהם מוביל לפרדי קצת שונות וחשוב בכל הקשר להבין לפי איזה מהם אנחנו רוצים להיות.
וזהו. זה להיום אנחנו נמשיך בדקדוק בשבוע הבא ואז נתחיל לדבר על.
הלקסיקון ופרויקטים בין אינדקס ומשם נעבור לניתוח תחבירי אוטומטי.
אני לא יודעת אם אני חושבת כך, אבל כנראה המתרגלים זה תרגיל לתרגיל.
טוב, אז מה זאת אומרת?
קודם כל. יוצאת מגדרה כדי לא לפגוע.
25. זה ממש לא בסדר.
זה שהקבוצה שהגישה אליה מוכרחה לצאת.
אפשר להוציא יותר. מצד שני.
אני קורא את זה פה אחד עוקץ. לא.
שנייה אחת. תגידי, עושים להם את המבחן בתוך המחברת, לא לחלק להם מחברות למבחנים.
לי שקיבלתי על זה המון עבודה, אבל מצד שני זה אדיר.
מסתדרים. אז אם את רוצה להתחלק עם החברות ואז את תעשי את הדף.
אני אחלק דפים עדיף. נראה לי מה שאת זה כמות גדולה.
אין בעיה. אני לא מסתדרת עם הדפים לאחרים אבל גדול יותר, נוח יותר.
מי שהגיע לבורגס בגיל פה.
גם. גברת.
צפו בקליפ חלק לצד הזה.
תבדקו. אי אפשר לחתום על זה בשנייה.
עכשיו אפשר לשלוט במצב? מכתב.
לא. איך אתה?
רואה את כל הזו?
לא מוכנה? אני רוצה לראות את שלכם.
זה לא. לכל אחד שירת את השיר.
רק. קשה.
לא. זה מרגיש גועל.
המשביר לצרכן. קשה לבוא לפה.
ככל. הוא פשוט מכין.
היא מחייכת ואומרת. בהצלחה.